[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir
nous vous recevons pour une chez
internity s'appelle singer view nous
sommes en direct on va parler ce soir de
finance de retraite de capacité du
système financier d'avoir une certaine
forme de résilience par rapport à
l'agressivité de l'air que nous
traversons messieurs est ce que vous
voulez bien vous présenter on va
commencer par françois xavier donc je
suis française y est c'est vrai je suis
directeur général de l'agirc-arrco le
régime de retraite complémentaire des
salariés du privé
à pierre sabatier je suis auvergnat
rugbyman ah non c'est pas ça en fait le
sujet je suis économiste j'ai fondé un
cabinet indépendant qui fait de la
recherche économique et financière
appliquée à la prise de décision qui
s'appelle preview est aussi cofondateur
d econoclaste et administrateur du
cercle turgot un cercle des économistes
on va vous la plupart au prénom serra
plus vite ça ne vous pose pas de
problème françois-xavier combien ça pèse
l'agirc arrco agirc arrco chaque année
ses 80 milliards d'euros de retraite
versées et c'est aussi 80 milliards
d'euros de cotisations collectées ça
c'est notre c'est la caractéristique
d'un régiment répartition comme comme
nous sommes 18 millions de d'actifs et
1,6 me d'entreprise qui cotisent pour
permettre à 12 millions de retraités de
recevoir tous les mois leur retraite
et puis par ailleurs c'est un peu une
originalité dans le paysage français on
a des réserves on a des actifs à hauteur
d'un peu plus de 60 milliards qui sont
70% des obligations de 30% des actions
et notre zone domestique
d'investissement c'est la zone euro donc
si je devais faire voilà c'est pour
donner un petit peu en terme en termes
de masse quand on est client
l'agirc-arrco on est client en moyenne
70 ans 40 à 45 ans de vie
professionnelle
20 à 25 ans de retraite
donc je crois qu'on est vous moi tous
ceux qui nous regardent
96% des français seront un moment ou un
autre de leur vie client nageurs carco
donc quand on réfléchit nous
l'agirc-arrco on se pose la question de
qu'est ce qu'on peut apporter comme
service pendant ses 70 ans comment on
garantit les retraites comme on garantit
les données pendant soixante dix ans
parce que finalement c'est un formidable
patrimoine immatériel mai c'est aussi
une formidable responsabilités bien ça
m'attire pierre quand vous regardez
l'activité quand tu regardes l'activité
jrc un coup quels sont les risques
auxquels ils peuvent être exposés
alors il ya forcément les risques de
court terme et puis les risques de long
terme je crois qu'en fait il faut
l'entendre sur ce plan les risques de
court terme l'époque comme tu l'évoqué
est troublée et donc lorsqu'on a un
portefeuille composé de 70 %
d'obligations et 30% en fait d'actions
de fait on est soumis en fait aux aléas
de marché et les alliances aériennes
marché malheureusement en fait ils sont
alors la plupart du temps tout se passe
bien mais parfois on est soumis en fait
à des accidents et l'époque très récente
à nous amener à vivre pour les marchés
financiers même si elle était très
courte cette époque brutale un choc
d'une brutalité qui s'il avait perduré
aurait pu mettre en difficulté l'agirc
arrco mais j'irai tout établissement
financier qui manipulent en eau ou qui
fait de l'investissement sur les marchés
puisque je rappelle les marchés actions
en quelques semaines ont perdu en europe
de mémoire 38% 38% c'est dire que vous
avez 100 en portefeuille vous n'avez
plus que voilà soixante 60 62 en fait
sur votre compte juste après alors
forcément quand vous avez après derrière
des des revenus à verser vous êtes
soumis alors dans un système par la
partition lorsque vous êtes des
cotisations qui permettent à avermes de
verser les prestations vous êtes un
petit peu protéger contre cela mais
d'une certaine manière vous réserve un
sens forcément affecté donc
comme tout établissement financier qui
joue sur les marchés financiers bon on
est soumis aux aléas donc les actions
forcément c c'est le risque qu'une les
actions cédées actions d'entreprises
qu'une entreprise du jour au lendemain
n'arrive plus à vendre de fait à la
décharge elle peut plus vendre plus de
recettes donc à un moment donné elle est
en difficulté c'est ce qui explique et
en fait le choc sur les actions les
obligations c'est à peu près la même
chose si ce n'est que vous avez prêté de
l'argent à quelqu'un il est plus en
mesure en fait de vous rembourser donc
le l'époque qu'on veut qu'on vient de
vivre c'était vraiment cette inquiétude
très forte
j'irai de
de la reproduction en fait des années 30
à savoir du jour au lendemain l'ensemble
des mécanismes financiers s'effondre pas
pour des raisons virtuel pour des
raisons réelles d'entreprises qui sont
mises ou d'états qui sont mises en
difficulté qui sont mises en faillite au
regard en fait de la conjoncture
économique alors ça c'est incroyable
c'était il ya quelques semaines et
pourtant on en parle au passé parce que
bon on a implémenté des politiques
nouvelles pour adresser en fait ce choc
d'une ampleur inédite depuis 90 ou 100
ans aujourd'hui on en est sorti la
question qui va se poser demain en fait
c'est pendant qu'en même temps dire
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
des politiques pour éviter justement
d'éviter ces faillite à court terme
est-ce que derrière ça aura des
conséquences plus lourdes qu'il faudra
dresser demain est-ce qu'on a simplement
repousser le problème c'est la question
qu'il faut se poser françois xavier j'ai
vu de mémoire vous allez me corriger si
je me trompe le gouvernement macron
infuser de vous donner des sous en fait
le gouvernement on a sollicité le
gouvernement pourrait être suffisante
alors peut-être pour pour compléter ce
point là nous on a deux poumons de
financement peut-être été un peu vite
dans la présentation on a le poumon
économique et que je veux dire
l'économie réelle c'est la masse
salariale ces entreprises c'est le sait
les caractéristiques variées répartition
et puis on a un deuxième poumon que la
partie financière et il est deux se
complètent pour garantir dans la durée
et le paiement des retraites et surtout
faire face au choc démographique et
économique qui sont les risques
inhérents c'est aussi content on a conçu
notre modèle je sais pas s'il est
robuste mais en tout cas avec cette idée
d'avoir chaque fois l'un qui peut
amortir l'autre c'est plus résilient
plus résilient la premier point deuxième
point nous notre modèle on l'a conçu en
1947 après la crise de 29 et après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et au départ
les régimes de retraite il était en
capitalisation chez et puis en fait
première ligne de gratte et puis arrive
la crise de 29 donc si on repart en
répartition 47 c'était la réponse à la
crise 29 mai et comme on savait qu'un
régiment répartition il peut aussi avoir
des aléas il y avait le 2 le deuxième le
deuxième bout ça c'est le premier gta
premier sujet après pour répondre à
votre question effectivement nous on a
eu un moment moindre moins de rentrées
de cotisations et donc la question qu'on
s'est posée c'est pour faire face à nos
enjeux de trésorerie est-ce qu'on allait
mobiliser nos obligations et nos actions
dans les conditions que des potes qui
même où est-ce qu'on mobilise est
désunie de trésorerie il se trouve que
la loi nous permettait sur papier de
mobiliser les outils de trésorerie de la
sécurité sociale donc on a demandé cela
l'état mais par ailleurs on a demandé
aussi aux grands gestionnaires d'actifs
de la place de de voir s'ils pouvaient
nous faire du prêt temporaire de titres
à quelles conditions l'état nous a
répondu non pour des questions de
liquidités parce que justement lacoste
avait des problèmes de refinancement est
donc finalement on a trouvé des
conditions tu t'es peut-être un tout
petit peu offert un tout petit peu moins
bonne que c'est que si c'était là qu est
ce qui ressort d à court terme auprès
des grands gestionnaires financiers vous
avez demandé combien vous aviez demandé
l' or l'occurrence on a dû mobiliser un
milliard sous forme de prêt temporaire
de titres wii ça donne ça donne une idée
la vraie question effectivement quelques
pour nous c'est sûr de ses songes de
trésorerie c'est quelle va être la
capacité de résilience de l'économie
française ce convoi nous c'est quand
même que quand on prend nos données de
d'encaissement pour nous mais aussi pour
la être l'ensemble de la cdu protection
sociale on a une bonne résilience c'est
à dire qu'on pensait avoir des taux
d'encaissement 50% et plus tôt à 70%
mais mais mais en même temps on est très
court terme on sait pas dire et ça
personne ne sait dire c'est tout le
débat des économistes gobain hugo banvit
gobant w voilà ça c'est un sujet éternel
ce qu'on s'est simplement c'est que nous
on a sécurisé le sujet de court terme
avec la capacité de la de mobiliser des
outils trésorerie et grâce à nos
réserves on a aussi de sécuriser le
moyen terme mais 60 milliards je disais
ouais 60 médias voilà il donc c'est pour
ça que c'est aussi en actions et
obligations parce que justement on sait
que les marchés sont pas nécessairement
sur les mêmes cycles et donc c'était
aussi pour pouvoir se dire parfois les
marchés obligation vaut mieux parfois
ces marchés actions et donc ça
permettait de diversifier les risques
pour reprendre le terme de terme ces
caractères résignant brésilien entre les
fondamentaux répartition et des réserves
pour compléter et dans les réserves des
obliques et des actions
juste après
quand je vous entends parler j'ai
l'impression d'entendre quelqu'un qui
protège ma retraite
et je me sens responsable de vous et
merci
je vais vous poser une question un petit
peu un peu plus tôt çi chez vous est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui font de la
prospective sur l'anticipation des
risques l'évaluation des risques le
chiffrement des risques commencent à se
compose ils sont combien quel profil
alors chez nous on a on a ce qu'on
appelle dans nos équipes une direction
technique dont son métier c'est de faire
de la projection c'est faire de la
projection sur les alliés allaient sur
l'économie sur la démographie des stress
tests d'alors d'abord sur la question à
l'heure où on y vient je viens d'abord
donc sûr et on part pour faire ses
opérations de projection pas sur nos
propres hypothèses parce que ce n'est
pas notre métier mais sur les hypothèses
des grandes institutions de la place et
notamment volontairement on a chez nous
un billet prudentielles ya comprend pas
les hypothèses des pouvoirs publics
français prend plutôt les hypothèses nos
tripes notre scénario central puis
l'homme c'est entre le mixte fmi-
commission européenne scénario donc on a
on assume ce caractère prudentielles et
quand on se projette on se projette à 15
ans parce que à 15 ans on a un horizon
qui globalement solides sur la
démographie sur l'économie et donc on
est sur un horizon prudentielles à 15
ans au delà on a des horizons à
cinquante ou soixante dix mais il y a
trop d'aléas pour en faire un horizon de
décision à l'horizon de projection mais
c'est pas un horizon décision mais quand
on se projette à 15 ans ont des les
partenaires sociaux parce que j'aurais
dû j'étais aussi un peu vite notre
caractéristique c'est qu'on est géré par
les organisations syndicales et
patronales d'originalité le dialogue
social ça marche dans le pays et ça
marche depuis 70 ans ils arrivent chaque
fois trouver une solution et donc je
sais que c'est souvent la meth reprise
je sais bien mais je sais bien mais ces
jeux là je suis à l'envers des idées
reçues voilà c'est de lever voilà et
parce qu'on est en règle parce qu'ils
sont en responsabilité et donc ils
décident sur des horizons quatre ans
mais sur un horizon 15 ans et dans notre
horizon dans notre scénario on doit
toujours avoir au moins six mois de
réserves sur 15 ans glissants parce que
justement comme je verse 80 comme nous
versons 80 milliards je doit au minimum
avoir 40 à 50 milliards de réserve parce
que nous savons que sur 15 ans on peut
avoir comme nous ils vont actuellement
des chocs économiques ou des chocs
démographiques et donc notre rôle c'est
de justement pour vous garantir pour
garantir à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
la robustesse du modèle et d'honorer la
promesse de la retraite par répartition
c'est justement de pouvoir avoir cet
élément qui absorbe la crise et qui
permet justement quand il ya des chocs
de pouvoir mesurer ce qui sont de court
terme puisqu'ils sont le moyen terme est
ce qu'il ya des éléments de pilotage qui
doivent être pris donc c'est pour ça ce
qu'on appelle chez nous pilotage
tactique puis de taches stratégique avec
l'idée de s'appuyer sur les grandes
tables de mortalité de l'insee de
rajouter parfois comme je l'évoquais des
prêtres des billets prudentielles et
donc par rapport à votre question des
stress tests oui c'est une forme
d'autres détestent parce que justement
on teste le modèle en ayant
systématiquement par rapport à ce que
parce qu'on pourrait avoir comme indice
de référence des éléments plus prudents
quand je ne compare par exemple soit en
termes de production avec un organisme
qui s'appelle le corps le conseil
d'orientation des retraites on accorde
le scénario il accorde un scénario de
croissance et de chômage à 15 ans
parlait au nom accor par le bas
c'est aussi un élément de prudence
bernard pas douter voilà à temps avant
de redonner vie au pire si on va parler
démographie
les trois menaces que vos cellule de
prospective ont identifié à moyen terme
et combien vous gagnez combien j'avais
combien je gagne bien ma vie c'est pas
c'est pas un sujet c'est pas dans notre
dans notre organisation est un public
dont je peux parler un petit verre d'où
je peux vous la donner mais je gagne
bien ma vie et je considère que c'est
quoi bien gagner sa vie c'est bien
gagner sa vie voilà je peux pas vous en
dire plus mais pas parce que comment
dirais-je ce que je sais c'est que j'ai
une responsabilité vis-à-vis au minimum
30 millions de français donc tous les
matins quand je me lève la question que
je me pose d'abord à moi c'est ce que je
suis digne de la confiance et ça c'est
pas de voie là et donc à partir de là et
dans ma rémunération un tiers c'est sur
mes résultats voilà donc si je suis pas
bon amélioration baisse d'un tiers
les trois menaces que vous avez
identifié à lettres des trois menaces
jédir nous dire il a déjà deux qui sont
l'économie la démographie sur la
démographie le risque de longévité
quelques de longévité quels sont les
indicateurs d'espérance de vie à court
et moyen terme et ça c'est des éléments
ce qu'on voit on sait que globalement on
gagne un trimestre d'espérance de vie
tous les ans tu sais ça c'est comme
allemand sur 15 ans à trimestre
d'espérance de vie il ya des aléas mais
quand vous prenez cela mais pourquoi
parce que l'économie devenue plus
tertiaires parce que les maladies que
les maladies mortelles sont devenus des
maladies chroniques et que la chaîne
alimentaire est devenue beaucoup plus
sécurisée qu'il ya quelques années donc
et globalement c'est pour ça que je
pourrais quand j'étais un peu vite sur
maladie morte mortel sur denis maladies
chroniques le sida l'insuffisance rénale
sont devenus des maladies chroniques
mouais du sida mourey des problématiques
cardiaque il ya 15 ans aujourd'hui on
vit avec durablement et donc ça c'est
aussi un facteur de prolongement de
l'espérance de vie l'autre élément qui
va simplement cédé 40 femmes qui se
résumait un peu parce que c'est bernard
kouchner qui le disait il ya 15 ans dans
le juste combat de l'égalité des femmes
vis-à-vis des hommes elles sont en train
de prendre les mauvaises habitudes des
hommes le tabac et l'alcool
on prend la pilule cdc confie-t-il mais
voilà c'est ça les aînés c'est très
compliqué
pierre alors il ya plein de choses qui
ont été dites et cyan hyper intéressante
parce que vraiment on touche à la notion
de prospective il ya un élément sur
lequel il faut vraiment s'arrêter c'est
la notion de diversification lorsqu'on
parle finances parce que en fait tout le
monde en fait nous sert la
diversification comme une meilleure
gestion du risque ça vient du fait que
moi en gros on met pas ses oeufs dans le
même panier grâce à cela on serait
protégée l'ours a véritablement il faut
l'interroger aujourd'hui je crois dans
les modèles de prospective tout
simplement parce que quand vous dites
modèle économique diversifié il ya un
banc cotisations donc un pan économique
directement à l' économie réelle et un
pan financiers historiquement
effectivement ils sont pas corrélées la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est ben
est ce que entre guillemets cette
décorrélation va perdurer on peut
s'interroger brillante locaux vides si
jamais on n'est pas des banques
centrales qui étaient descendus dans la
cave concrètement émettre des billets de
banque pour les données concrètement on
est face à quoi faire une feinte on est
face à une crise économique dans crise
économique à terme aboutir à a entre
guillemets du chômage moins de
cotisations donc concrètement là vous
êtes face à ce risque là et en parallèle
de quoi vous pouvez très bien avoir en
fait le risque financier parce que bon
il faut être très clair dire que si
jamais on arrive à des taux de
décroissance qui sont 10% ainsi jamais
malheureusement l'année prochaine en
fait on rebondit pas c'est un scénario
qui peut être envisagée même si ce n'est
pas forcément le scénario central est
mis à cette perte d'emploi cette perte
de profitabilité des boîtes fera que
leur valeur elle-même sera amené à
décroître hier que la notion de
diversification des modèles elle est
intellectuellement intéressante mais
elle doit être interrogé aujourd'hui
parce que fait le fait d'avoir un côté
finances un côté économie
malheureusement ou heureusement d'une
certaine manière l'un et l'autre peuvent
aller dans le même sens c'est le premier
point le deuxième point sur la notion de
diversification lorsqu'on se concentrent
mettront sur les éléments financiers sur
les portefeuilles financiers actions
obligations sujet hyper intéressant
effectivement pour que les gens aient
enfin lorsque les gens me faire pour que
les gens comprennent en général
en général les actions les obligations
elle fonctionne de manière antinomique à
savoir quand les actions montent vais
souvent des obligations qui baisse et
inversement ça c'était en fait la
relation traditionnelle historique
depuis des angles 10 ans s'est terminée
aujourd'hui en fait vous pouvez très
bien vous en faites des actions qui
baissent en même temps que des
obligations en fait qui baisse et c'est
ça en fait le vrai sujet principal c'est
que pendant longtemps parce que c'est
simple à comprendre
on a dit il suffit pour gérer le risque
de diversifier je crois aujourd'hui
qu'on est à la veille d'un moment durant
lequel il faut s'interroger sur le fait
qu' est-ce que la différencie la
diversification suffit à gérer le risque
et donc c'est la question fondamentale
parce que quand d'une action quand d'une
obligation faite en gros vous avez un
titre de propriété d'un côté une dette
de l'autre en réalité lorsque c'est la
même entreprise qui l'aimé et bien s'il
est en difficulté ou en grande
difficulté évidemment sa valeur va
diminuer mais sa capacité à rembourser
sa dette aussi et donc vous pourrait en
fait être pris au piège finalement d'une
diversification factice qui doit vous
servir d'assurance en cas de coup dur et
qui malheureusement souvent comme les
assurances au moment où vous en avez
besoin faites vous sert plus à l'est
n'est plus valable et donc je crois
véritablement pour le goût dans le monde
de la projection dans le monde de la
prospective faire attention à ne pas
projeter des tendances en fait qu'ils
sont des tendances longues parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est pro à le mans au
devant de monde qui va changer qui est
en train de changer sur le plan
économique sur le prend pour le mans
sociétal on y reviendra après parce que
la notion des retraités touchent
évidemment à la société mais aussi sur
le plan financier avec des nouvelles
choses qui sont mises en place qui ont
des impacts de court terme et qui auront
aussi pour l'amender impact de long
terme qu'on a aujourd'hui du mal à
appréhender
deux éléments pour aller dans ce sens-là
nous notre modèle c'est le résultat
phadia c'est un modèle qui a la foi qui
veut garantir un risque de long je le
disais on est client 70 ans donc notre
responsabilité c'est d'honorer ce risque
que l'on en même temps quand j'évoquais
nos horizons de deux décisions à quatre
ans de projection à 15 ans ont
régulièrement leur et interroge ont
leurré interroge à la fois dans notre
zone d'investissement mais aussi j'ai
été un peu vite aussi deuxième et
comment on investit conte avec six coups
sûrs d'eux que sur des titres liquides
ou est-ce qu'on favorise aussi la
création d'emplois dans l'économie
française et donc c'est sur les actifs
illiquides parce que là effectivement
c'est aussi une autre manière de nous
diversifier le risque c'est notre poumon
et de là je reviens de poumons c'est
l'année du dynamisme de l'économie
française donc c'est comment nous dans
notre rôle d'investisseur institutionnel
on contribue aussi à favoriser le
développement d'entreprises qui vont
elles mettre dans des secteurs
d'activités dans les heures des
territoires qui vont elles mêmes être
créateur d'emplois dans la durée donc
mais c'est aussi ne pas être court
termiste dans la proche au sens dans
notre dos nous dû avoir une approche qui
soit où irait on est deux hémisphères
qui ne se réunit pas entre l' approche
économique et la presse financière à la
fois ce que vous évoquez à juste titre
c'est le côté mais il peut en fait on
peut moins là où on ait un sentiment de
diversifier en fait on concentre mais
surtout c'est aussi la question de
comment on stratifie notre horizon
d'investissement on a des poches de
court terme on a des poches de moyen
terme et quand on est sur des actifs
illiquides on sait qu'on va immobiliser
des fonds pendant dix ans 12 ans et donc
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on va millésime
et nos investissements pour justement
pouvoir à la fois parce qu'on sait que
le marché tout le monde veut investir ce
soit ce marasme de ce fameux mars marché
l'a donc le marché n'est pas aussi
liquidé profond qu'on pourrait le
souhaiter mais aussi pour pouvoir être
raisonné sur les horizons glissant qui
permettent en segmentant et en millésime
en aux horizons d'investissement de
pouvoir essayer de lisser les éléments
de risque après ce qui est vrai c'est
que tu dirais tout modèle il est
régulièrement réinterroger et dans son
caractère cyclique procyclique
contracyclique pas régulièrement nous
est si vous voulez chaque fois qu'il ya
eu des grandes crises économiques on a
été amené à tester la robustesse de
notre modèle et avec les partenaires
sociaux à s'assurer si on devait
corriger tel ou tel outil de pilotage et
tel ou tel instrument donc c'est pas un
élément c'est un élément qui donne des
exemples récents des exemples récents je
peux vous dire qu'en 2015 si vous
m'aviez interrogé en 2015 voler les
confrères titrait faillite de l'aja
carco point d'interrogation et là on
nous annonçait plus de réserves plus de
réserves l'agirc arrco plus de réserve à
l'agirc à l'époque plus réservé à
l'agility 3 ans les retraites des cadres
allaient baisser de 13% l'antienne puis
plus de réserve à l'arrco plus de
réserve alors qu en 2023/2024 donc à ce
moment là ray donc parce qu'on était sur
une situation qui était compliqué
c'était les suites de la crise de 2010
sport et donc à ce moment là on a une
négociation qui a duré six mois mais à
l'issue de la négociation les
partenaires sociaux ont pris des mesures
de court terme ont pris des mesures de
moyen terme et je peux vous dire qu'on
était revenu à l'équilibré avant que
avant la période covit parce que ça a
été parce qu un régime de retraite en
répartition c'est comme un paquebot un
porte avions c'est eux ça se pilote à
moyen terme et d'une certaine manière
c'est aussi rassurant parce que c'est
les cotisations chacun d'entre nous
c'est pas une us est pas une esquif donc
effectivement on a on l'a on a pris des
décisions les partenaires sociaux prix
d'émission qui l'ont remis qui l'ont
remis à l' équilibre et qui lui ont
permis d'arriver dans une situation
l'attend pour répondre à votre question
on a été on a vu la même problématique
alors pour les plus anciens d'entre nous
en 1993 quand la question s'était posée
on a eu la même problématique entre les
deux ans 2009-2010 donc c'est chaque
fois que notre économie connaît un choc
important
finalement le modèle le mode d'autres
modèles il est éprouvée et donc c'est à
ce moment là que la décision amène est
être prises mais là la force de tenir
enfin la force au sens notre expérience
prouve que comme on a cessé ses deux
poumons là on a le temps de prendre des
décisions du coup de moyen et de long
terme le risque doute en ce moment là
c'est réagir d'être myope d'être myope
par rapport à l'événement et donc c'est
pour ça que quand j'évoquais fait
convives de ce conte convives sur la
riviera qu'on est assis sur la masse
salariale et sur l'économie et qu'on a
le poumon financier qu'on a par ailleurs
cet horizon de 15 ans glissants cet
objectif de 6 mois ça a été conçu comme
une forme de règle d'or pour faire face
à ces aléas de l'économie et de la
démographie et pour pouvoir quand il ya
des chocs profond pouvoir prendre alors
un peu de profondeur historique pour
pouvoir prendre des décisions et
garantir et garantir le paiement est
garanti mais plus que le paiement
garantir la promesse si j'ai bien
compris
compris votre poche de réserve ses six
mois c'est ça ne fonctionne non c'est
d'avoir au moins six mois aujourd'hui on
est à 9 mois de mai mais notre règle
d'or ne doit jamais descendu en dessous
de 6 mois parce qu'on sait quand on
descend en dessous de 6 mois on a plus
de mal à le reconstituer donc c'est
d'avoir toujours sur 15 ans glissants si
moins de réserves six mois ça fait pas
beaucoup bah ça fait 40 à 50 milliards
mais ça fait pas beaucoup passé oui mais
on est un régime de retraite en
répartition donc par ailleurs j'ai on à
la masse salariale notre expérience
prouve quand même que même si c'est pas
beaucoup ça permet ça vous donne de la
visibilité sur plusieurs années vient
alors le sujet économique est en fait
c'est le pendant est l financier il ya
le démographique dans la prospective
c'est intéressant et je pense qu'en fait
il serait intéressant qu'on s'y attarde
lorsque démographique dont il ya déjà un
élément concret pour les retraites ainsi
le nombre tout simplement parce que la
personne n'est sans savoir en fait que
par bonheur en fait effectivement
l'espérance de vie augmente mais aussi
en fait on a tout un tas de génération
en fait de baby boomer qui arrivent à
l'âge de la cessation d'activité et donc
la vraie question fondamentale aussi
pour les régimes de retraite c'est
finalement même dans un régime par par
répartition lorsqu'on a comme
aujourd'hui à peu près 30 6 millions de
personnes en france qui entre 20 et 65
ans en 2030 ans ils seront aussi 36
millions donc après une base de
cotisation alors même si pour vous il
faudrait entrer dans des tailles pas ce
qu'est la notion de cadre à versus
n'encadre mais bon globalement il ya 36
millions de personnes qui ont entre 20
et 26 65 ans est sa vraie c'est à peu
près le cas jusque 1 jusqu'en 2030 alors
dans l'hypothèse où on arrive à les
faire travailler donc c'est une
hypothèse quand même optimiste qu'on
arrive à tous et faire travailler il
faudra quand même faire face à une
génération de plus de 65 ans qui passe
grosso modo de douze treize millions
aujourd'hui à 16 millions demain donc la
vraie question fondamentale c'est
comment et sur quelle base vous arriver
à équilibrer un mécanisme qui va vouloir
forcément au niveau global des retraites
pas forcément en fait que sur leur
retraite des cadres arrivé à assumer le
fait qu'il va y avoir beaucoup plus de
prestations en volume en nombre en fait
à assumer par rapport à en fait un
volant de cotisation qui au mieux reste
se stabilisera en sachant que voilà il
n'ya pas qu'en fin voilà la vraie
question en fait le risque en fait
démographique il est il interrogé
l'intérêt de la france et il interroge
tout le monde c'est vrai est ce que on
se cache pas derrière son petit doigt
face à l'explosion fait du monde de
prestations à servir en volume comment
faire pour assurer en fait un régime
équilibré sur la base en fête des
fondations sur lequel il était conçu par
le passé enfin vous aviez la patate
chaude alors japon déjà sur ce sujet
revient sur la question des six mois
parce que ça permet de
diversion pas dit non non j'ai dans ma
réponse au final ces sommes là d'où
vient-elle elles viennent des
cotisations des entreprises et des
salariés si on disait c'est pas 6 mois 9
mois ces deux ans ça voudrait dire qu'on
doit demander un effort aux entreprises
et aux salariés important lors disant
voodoo tofu de confier vos cotisations
on les met de côté mais donc ça aurait
un impact soit sur le montant de la
fraude soit sur le montant des
cotisations appelées donc retenez que le
débat va le débat où le calibrage je
formule est plutôt comme sapin fait six
6 mois 9 mois c'est de trouver le bon
équilibre entre l'effort qui est demandé
aux entreprises et aux salariés et
qu'est-ce qui est donc pour qu'est-ce
qui est mis de côté pour faire face aux
aléas et qu'est ce qui est immédiatement
versés sur la clé pour agression douglas
et retenons que globalement plus un
régime à une assiette large - il est un
peu un nombre de mois de réserves
élevées à voir parce qu'il a une
assiette large et donc si un secteur
économique connaît une crise un autre
secteur peut connaître un autre cycle
économique plus un régime et 3 plus il a
besoin d'avoir des roses des réserves
élevées parce que là il a une assiette
beaucoup plus large et donc qui peut
connaître des variations à la masse
salariale au beaucoup plus élevé donc
c'était juste pour rappeler cette
question de six mois versus 9 mois ou un
an ou deux en dix ans mais si moi c'est
peut-être pas assez mais retenait que si
on en voulait beaucoup plus un jour
j'aurai plaisir à venir voir tout les
chefs d'entreprise de notre pays et où
les salariés en leur disant chers amis
il me serait agréable que vous qu'odile
avantage donc je ne suis pas sûr que ça
serait jeu ça serait perçue en termes de
pouvoir d'achat comme un élément positif
d'où la question du compromis après la
question la question sur la question
mais finalement la question de la
démographie nous serons quand on se
projette je l'évoquais on est partis sur
des tables de mortalité ou des tables de
longévité pour être plus positif où on a
intégré le non seulement la progression
individuelle mais aussi l'effet baby
boom et il est fait les faits niés ou
alors ce qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
quand même c'est que les générations nos
générations je pourrais la génération
suivante arrive de plus en plus tard sur
le marché du travail donc naturellement
elles partiront aussi de plus en plus de
de plus en plus tard il a vraie question
c'est le ratio individuels entre le
nombre d'années en activité par rapport
le nombre d'années en retraite c'est
comme ça l'équilibré un titre individuel
je pourrai dire à titre individuel
certains s'est dit mais finalement quel
est mon taux de retour de mes
cotisations c'est j'ai cotisé 40 ou 45
ans combien de temps je vais les avoir
nous ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que
ce choc démographique dans nos dents
notable de projection on l'a anticipé on
sait que on a le point que simplement
qu'on n'a pas terminé c'est qu'on fait
qu'on considère que la population active
est un invariant tana variant or ce
sujet de la population active quels sont
les deux points qui peuvent les faire
bouger il ya un premier sujet qui est le
nombre combien il ya de personnes qui
travaillent dans notre pays deuxième
élément est donc ça renvoie au débat de
la démographie mais aussi la formation
professionnelle qui a laissé le quid de
la qualité de la formation pour un chien
et au lac saint point deuxième élément
c'est aussi les gains de productivité de
l'économie française c'est aussi le
dynamisme c'est pas qu'un effet de
nombres si on à dire et un meilleur taux
de croissance on sera prêt de 30
millions mais chacun d'entre nous sera
un peu mieux rémunérés microïds
attendait la question ces versets 1 des
voix d'économistes est ce qu'on aime
est-ce qu'on est sur un débat de la
stagnation séculaire ou pas si on a
l'humilité dire personne n'en sait rien
ce sentiment que personne n'en sait rien
c'est comme le débat du vélo de mes
joueuses mais là je m'élève au delà de
ma condition pardon pardon mais voilà
ben mais voilà et donc pour moi parce
que c'est tout le débat de c'est surtout
le débat de ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que le débat de la masse salariale
pour le dire différemment c'est un effet
volumes et un effet prix quand
j'entendais françois-xavier parler j'ai
l'impression qu'il a des lunettes roses
qui joue qu'il est sur le fil du rasoir
tout le temps parce qu'il doit aussi
avoir les pouvoirs publics qui vous met
un peu la pression aussi parce que vous
êtes eu quand même une variable
d'ajustement pour le pouvoir d'achat
pour la
la confiance des gens vous êtes quand
même une sacrée variable d'ajustement
donc est ce que pierre vous n'avez pas
l'impression que votre voisin de droite
est quand même super optimiste alors
super optimiste c'est un état général je
pense que dans notre société on
gagnerait du temps et de l'efficacité
être précis sur les questions donc la
vraie question qui vient d'être posée
c'est le niveau de croissance et aux
trois ans à venir et en fait ils iront
alors là pour le coup c'est un vrai
débat un débat de fond sur la stagnation
séculaire on est ni pour ni contre en
fait la question c'est quelle conviction
n'a sur le comportement des gens parce
que premièrement n'oublions pas que
l'économie ce n'est pas autre chose que
l'agrégation des comportements de nos
concitoyens ce sont des agents privés
que sont des ménages des entreprises et
à quoi à côté duquel vit en fait l'agent
public donc c'est ça une économie
globale et si on veut avoir une idée en
fait des taux de croissance à venir faut
s'interroger sur le comportement de tous
ces acteurs au milieu au coeur en fête
de notre économie et qui ya les gens il
ya les concitoyens et donc la question
fondamentale c'est pour ça que j'ai
abordé la notion de démographie sous
deux plans qu'est ce qu'on constate en
termes démographiques y à votre
problématique en tant que tel en termes
de nombre de cotisants versus nombre de
prestataires à servir et donc là
effectivement c'est un mécanisme
évidemment dit s'il y en a il y en a
certains qui sont faciles certains sont
pas plus nombreux et que d'autres sont
beaucoup plus nombreux il va y avoir un
déséquilibre mais en réalité l'impact
démographique l'impact démographique il
est surtout économique dans le nôtre et
dans notre capacité à générer de la
croissance de demain je m'explique en
réalité on constate que le comportement
d'un consommateur vous avez compris que
c'est vraiment le coeur du sujet en fait
nos concitoyens la manière dont ils
consomment en réalité d'un point de vue
démographique ce qu'on constate c'est
que partout dans le monde dans tous les
pays riches la manière dont on consomme
les gens est assez stable en fonction de
son âge et ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on consomme
de plus en plus entre 20 et 45 40 45 55
ans vous êtes à peu près sur des niveaux
de consommation au top après 55 ans vous
avez tendance en fait avoir votre niveau
de consommation commence à baisser c'est
logique et vous êtes tout à fait famille
avec la chose pourquoi parce qu'en fait
les gens se rendent compte que bientôt
ils vont être en cessation d'activité
est donc globalement il se prépare il ya
un effet en fait préparation à la
retraite qui est évident où les gens
arbitre un peu plus en défaveur de la
consommation et un peu plus en faveur d'
épargne pour se préparer pourquoi ils se
préparaient à quoi se préparer
simplement en fait au décalage de
revenus mais qu'ils subiront parce que
lorsqu'on regarde le taux de
remplacement entre le les revenus en
fait de la dernière année d'activité
versus les revenus en retraite et ben il
ya un décrochage qui peut aller en fait
de 30 à 40% donc les gens grosso modo en
fait vont se préparer à cela et après
l'âge de la retraite qu'est ce qu'on
constate on constate que les sommes
dépensées en fait ont tendance à
décliner ça c'est un invariant en
réalité c'est un invariant fait dans le
temps ce qui est assez intéressant dire
qu'en fait la nature humaine nous amène
en fait d'avoir ce type de comportements
qui sont assez logiques et c'est en
navarre ya en fait aussi géographique
c'est ça qui est intéressant de regarder
le japon ou les états unis les espagnols
et américains les italiens les français
en fait à peu près la même forme de
comportement il avait en fait de la
consommation or lorsque vous savez que
vous êtes face une société qui dit c'est
ni bien ni mal c'est comme ça tant mieux
on est heureux en fait qu'on ait cette
fiabilité qui augmente mais concrètement
fait notre société vit à partir de ce
moment là lorsque vous avez une société
qui évolue avec de plus en plus de
seniors versus des gens potentiellement
là je travaille et qui n'augmentent plus
bien naturellement en gros votre
espérance de croissance de la
consommation de main et le décline et
votre et donc de fait puisque une
entreprise investit pourquoi s'investir
pour vendre vendre acquis aux
concitoyens aux consommateurs mais d'une
certaine manière en fait vous avez un
effet domino qui centrait mais c'est
pour ça que la notion style stagnation
séculaire on n'est ni pour ni contre
mais concrètement elle le sent elle
n'est simplement fait la disparition de
la croissance progressive sans aller à
la décroissance on est en train de faire
de la politique elle n'est que la
conséquence de nos propres révolutions
d'ailleurs il ya un pays qui est
intéressant même s'il a des
particularismes ou bien particulier
c'est japon japon qu'elle commence à
vieillir en fait il ya peu près à peu
près voilà maintenant 25 ans et qui
depuis le milieu des années 90 à partir
du moment où certains pays qu'il
commence à vivre de manière accélérée et
bien n'a plus de croissance n'y a plus
d'inflation les japonais
individuellement sont pas plus pauvres
il s'en porte pas plus mal mais
concrètement en fait tous les modèles
qui sont basés sur la croissance pour
générer suffisamment de revenus et
continue à payer tout le monde mais
concrètement s'effondre tout simplement
parce que le postulat de base c'est
comme l'axiome de base en mathématiques
n'est plus là il ya que si vous baser un
modèle économique sur la base de la
croissance ou de l'augmentation des
revenus et que les revenus n'augmentent
pas ou augmente peu ou pas assez
concrètement vous fragilisez de
l'ensemble du mécanisme donc c'est
vraiment une question centrale la notion
d'espérance
la mission de croissance potentielle
quel est le potentiel qu'on peut espérer
en termes de croissance ce n'est pas une
question philosophie ce n'est même pas
une question de productivité parce que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
productivité dans des économies mais
depuis 40 ans la productivité générale
elles baissent elles baissent elle
augmente d'un point de vue individuel
travers la robotisation mais au niveau
des sociétés elle ne cesse de baisser
depuis 40 ans donc d'une certaine
manière tout cas basé nos projections
sur la base de gains de productivité ça
nous paraît aléatoire et surtout la
compréhension de l'évolution
démographique de nos sociétés nous
amènent à simplement acté le fait qu'il
faut qu'on construise des modèles qui
soient pérennes et résilient avec peu de
croissance en soccer 3 3 éléments ça me
permet de répondre à tous les deux je
fais taquiner sur le caractère je devine
des trudonnaires ça c'est que le départ
je sais bien mais j'aime bien j'aime
bien sûr ces discussions lors pour dire
un peu parce que j'ai été dans le propos
j'ai pas donné de chiffres nous notre
scénario central c'est 1% de taux de
croissance je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'on voit ça pour le coup c'est plutôt
raisonner voilà donc le jeu cas je
qualifiais nos caractères prudentielles
s'ouvre la cour des comptes quand elle
joue une coupe vote vote scénario 5 1%
de croissance ok et si je vous mets un
scénario avec 2 % de récession nommé à
bord sans sur 15 ans c'est à dire que je
après j'ai un débat de combien si j'ai 2
% combien sabotage 1 1% sur 15 à 20 %
tous les ans fonctions exponentielles
bas 1 % tous les ans et 1 % tous les ans
sur 15 ans sur 15 ans ça fait combien de
% basse et après vous vous mettez un
poids puissance 15
mai donc voilà donc pour dire qu'on est
plutôt parti sur un scénario prudent et
quand je dis scénario prudent que la
cour des comptes quand elle qualifie les
ja carco dit finalement l'un des rares
le côté cogestion à l'allemande ce côté
volontairement prudente on assume on
assume donc je les corrige j'évoquais
tout à l'heure horizon projection
d'autres horizons décision j'ai pu moi
dans mon esprit je préfère annoncer des
bonnes nouvelles que des mauvaises
nouvelles rideau défensif du pru dans
les pompes à essence moi je sais pas si
c'est défensif dit prudent prudence et
plus notre défensive je sais pas mais
prudence et je préfère ce que d'autres
sont aussi pertinentes un filet d'eau
tiède ouais non mais je ne sais pas
défensif je commence à rentrer dans le
jugement de valeur prudent je sais que
je suis plutôt à me dire je ne rentre
pas dans le jugement de valeur mais
j'assume ce juge ce côté c'est votre
droit voilà c'est moi je pourrais dire
aujourd'hui on monte plus ça dans les
zones civiles ont des bons pères de
famille à une époque ça fait un peu
ringard de dire ça mais ce côté
voilà en tout cas c'est ce côté moi je
dis souvent les salariés français nous
confient leurs cotisations retraite on
leur doit des hypothèses prudentes parce
que si on doit pour justement leur
garantie à la retraite la meilleure
retraite parce qu'ils ont confié ces
mets y compris dans le temps le choix
des investissements y compris dans les
supports d'investissement si je devais
je crois que c'était là mais comment
dirais-je un écran investi américain qui
disait si on comprend pas on n'investit
pas c'est aussi ça parce que c'est ce
que moi je le dis souvent y compris
quand les plus modestes me confisque
leurs cotisations retraite je leur doit
de garantir ce de la compréhension des
mécanismes des compréhensions inquiète
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
sur la question effectivement du débat
sur la question de la démographie cette
question là les centrales après ne
considérons pas aussi que la démographie
c'est un jeu à somme nulle pourquoi je
vais déplacer le sujet regardons la
politique de l'allemagne vis-à-vis des
réfugiés du moyen-orient allemagne
société vieillissante la politique
d'ouverture c'était aussi de se dire
mais finalement mais pays quand on prend
l'histoire du pays notre pays pourquoi
au 19e siècle la france a été un pays
d'immigration parce qu'il avait fait sa
transition démographique au xviiie
siècle donc il manquer de main d'oeuvre
donc le débat de la main d'oeuvre
économique c'est aussi quand on prend
l'histoire de nos pays quand on prenait
tous les soirs des pays européens c'est
pas qu'un sujet du taux de natalité du
taux de fécondité dans le pays c'est un
des sujets centrale mais c'est aussi la
question et là on rentre dans une
approche internationale y compris sur la
question des comparaisons des taux de
croissance oui les pays développés sont
plus de 30s quand on prend des pays plus
récents on a plutôt eu des croissances
plus plus récentes voilà il était avec
des niveaux ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que dans le débat de la question
de la population active et de la masse
salariale de raison non pas uniquement
dans un jeu à somme nulle doute le cas
du japon vous évoquez de mémoire c'est
impossible c'est une île comme direct
andré siegfried fleurs en montagne c'est
une yeux et c'est y compris dans son
rapport à l'étranger c'est aussi cette
question alors du coup je m'interroge
maintenant je pense que c est une île
c'est vrai c'est pour ça que j'ai en
fait véritablement lorsque vous
connaissez le japon japon au japon avec
des japonais là pour le coup la notion
de flux migratoires et les régler il y
en a pas après le cas de l'allemagne est
intéressant quand même là vous évoquez
en fait justement les flux migratoires
qui sont arrivés en allemagne récemment
mais ça aboutit à quoi est-ce que ça
c'était horrible concrètement compensé
une faiblesse démographique interne par
des flux migratoires entre les mains
externe par des migrations concrètement
ça aboutit à quoi au fait que mme merkel
ne se représente pas alors là pour le
coup elle a été un peu plus popularisé
par la crise du coup vide mais un
réalité un million d'émigrés en
allemagne ça aboutit en fait à son échec
c'est un peu comme si on raisonnait de
manière théorique et livresque
concrètement il faut avoir en tête que
une action amène une réaction et les
populations aujourd'hui dans nos pays
c'est une question je m'interroge est-ce
que aujourd'hui répondre à notre
problématique démographique par des flux
migratoires est-ce que c'est acceptable
politiquement et socialement par nos
populations la réponse est claire ces
dernières années en fait tous les pays
ont fait font la même réponse
politiquement parlant tous les votes
nous amène à croire que les populations
ont fait n'accepteront pas cette
solution donc la réalité c'est que
effectivement on pourrait penser qu'on
pourrait répondre à une faiblesse
démographique par des flux migratoires
la réalité c'est qu'il ya le moyen de
croissance géothermie des propos c'est
concret 1 c'est vraiment terre à terre
c'est mon côté auvergnat désolé même
ingénieur agronome j'aurais pu lire
résolu mais non mais c'est une fierté
mais les membres en voilà mais
alors j'ai perdu mon fils bien sûr
l'ambition des plus notoires sur la wii
autre chose et là ça tombe sous le sens
la réalité c'est que même est ce que les
populations peuvent-elles accepté entre
guillemets plus de demandes ou des
afflux au moment même entre limay où la
croissance disparaît la croissance c'est
quoi c'est la taille du gâteau à se
partager
malheureusement il est beaucoup plus
facile entre guillemets d'attirer des
gens lorsque la taille du gâteau à se
partager augmente que lorsqu elle
n'augmente plus et notre problématique
justement c'est que aujourd'hui notre
croissance sont faibles en bourse ans
est faible ils baisseront même peut-être
au-delà en fait de 1 % 1 % dans les
années à venir et c'est que c'est pas du
gâteau à se partager qu'il n'augmente
plus rendra politiquement extrêmement
difficile à implémenter des politiques
de flux migratoires pour compenser en
fait l'absence de vieillir démographique
donc c'est une solution qui est
intellectuellement peut-être acceptable
mais qui à mon sens est politiquement et
socialement totalement utopique et
d'ailleurs quels sont les discours qui
gagne en politique au cours des
dernières années c'est assez donald
trump c'est bruce johnson c'est en
italie je ne fais pas de politique se
dire je le constate à dire que le
message que donnent les populations
c'est qu'un en tout cas aller dans cette
direction là aujourd'hui et
politiquement perdant appartement où
c'est politiquement perdant il est dit
si de les implémenter ou d'implémenter
cc prospective là dans nos modèles
quand il n'y a plus de fonds dans les
râteliers les chevaux se bat non alors
brave ya plusieurs éléments premiers
éléments mon propos était de dire 'ne
raisons non pas comme si nous étions une
économie fermée c'était juste ça le
propos était de dire je pourrais que je
dors dix ans les éléments que ce soit en
économie ou en démographie on n'est pas
dans une économie fermée bon et quand on
prend l'histoire notre pays après je
vous disais juste par rapport à l'état
de nos populations et autres mais
c'était une manière de penser je sais
pas si c'est out of the box mais pas
m'étonner note ne s'est pas des données
qui sont là qui sont qui sont affichés
après l'une des questions et c'est l'une
des questions et c'est pour ça que je
dis que quand on est sur ses horizons là
on n'est pas à 6 mois ou à trois ans on
est à 15 ans à 20 ans 25 ans donc c'est
la question du temps long c'est la
question du temps long si j'étais si je
voulais faire historien de l'immigration
je rappellerai mais ce n'est pas le
sujet que malheureusement l'immigration
n'a jamais été un long fleuve tranquille
quand on prend l'accueil des italiens
dans notre pays à la fin du 19ème
c'était pas un long fleuve tranquille
contre pour les qualités pour le tester
mais c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui il
s'est pas levé puisque c'est pas ma
fonction c'est en 1966 avec au moins 2 %
de croissance et ce n'était pas ma
fonction mais quand vous prenez à la fin
du 19ème je suis pas sûr que c'était des
éléments voilà ce que je veux dire par
là c'est vrai ce que vous dites est
évidemment c'est vrai mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que quand on est
amené à penser la pérennité d'un système
de retraite soit dit en passant qui soit
en répartition et capitalisation et là
il ya le même degré de fragilité exact
est ce que vous dites là c'est plutôt
comment était là je pense que c'est un
des éléments de fanions c'est comment on
arrive à garantir le financement jaillir
de nos grandes fonctions collective dans
un régime de si on nous étions dans un
régime de faible croissance durable
c'est ça la question quelle est la
question la question auquel en conquête
on aura tous à répondre d'une manière ou
d'une autre et c'est ça la question et
c'est là tout simplement ce que nous
notre expérience nous prouve c'est qu'on
a parfois une forme de deux il ya des
éléments contre socke annoncé pas
répondre dans l'instant et ho kelly
j'allais dire parfois il faut pas
essayer de répondre l'instant parce
qu'on n'a pas l'ensemble des éléments
pour pouvoir discerner en pleine
connaissance voilà c'est ça les éléments
c'est pour ça que je renvoyais au
caractère prudent sur ce genre envoyés
dans d'autres nous dans nos tient en
responsabilité à désir on a un
on a constitué ces éléments face des
mondes amortisseurs pour pouvoir
permettre d'avoir un peu de recul pour
pouvoir décider de manière efficiente
parce qu'au final pour pelle dans des
questions de principe mais dans les
questions de modalités si on veut
pouvoir garantir la promesse c'est
comment on arrive à lui faire à lui
faire passer à lui faire surmonter les
différends aller à l'économie et de la
démographie et ce qui est vrai en tout
cas mais je pense que c'est aussi un
point c'est ce qu'on vit là on imagine
toujours intellectuellement qu'on va
c'est un peu un mauvais moment à passer
qu'on va revenir à la situation
antérieure alors que là l'un des enjeux
que nous avons c'est comment on arrive à
dessiner progressivement un nouvel
équilibre je viendrai centre est pris
également en disant comment faire avaler
la pilule
non j'ai pas été là dessus mais pardon
dans les débats je vais être un peu
provoc mais dans le débat du taux de
remplacement par mois ou mais pendant
mes larmes et les le niveau de vie des
retraités n'a jamais été aussi élevé
dans le pays le niveau de vie des
retraites en valeur absolue n'a jamais
été aussi aisément est témoin d'une
certaine manière les grandes places mais
non je peux pas le nombre de standards
en place de tout remplacement par le pas
dans
les actes balayée par des vents
d'agit-prop séjour de m'exprimer ainsi
n'ont ils donc ce que je veux dire par
là moi je cite une seule chose dont j'ai
fait un tout petit peu plus un
publireportage croix de chavaux je ne
sais pas quel est le bon niveau de
retraite pour chacun d'entre nous ce que
je sais simplement c'est parce que cette
question qui est éminemment personnel on
a nous mis en place un simulateur de
retraite que vous trouvez sur le site de
l'aja croquer le simulateur de retraite
de tous les régimes de retraite je vous
invite à aller le voir vous authentifier
avec votre numéro insee vos numéros de
cin q et vous aurez vous aurez à la fois
tout ce qu'on sait sur vous tous que
toute la carrière professionnelle
conseil sur vous et et surtout vous
pourrez simuler vos choix de vie voilà
et donc et après vous aurez bas si je
pars était là je combien j'aurais si je
pars un peu plus tôt combien j'aurais
autres et là ça vous permettra de faire
un choix éclairé je n'ai pas donc c'est
un outil d aide à la décision pour faire
des choix éclairés et donc vous pouvez
aussi tester comment vous voyez
l'évolution de vos revenus comment vous
voyez l'évolution de revenus évidemment
plus on est proche de la retraite plus
l'élément est solide parce que la
carrière passée est importante plus on
est loin mais si j'ai si j'étais un peu
si j'étais un peu malicieux est ce que
vous connaissez prix de l'immobilier à
cinq ans sans doute pas que région bah
voilà déjà déjà on va essayer va prendre
le le bassin auvergnats qu'elle est
privée
pour dire aussi que l'une parle
prospective aussi ces éléments là ils
compris en termes de simulation côté
prospectifs tiens un élément très
intéressant si je vous taquine un petit
peu c'est que fait votre sujet
aujourd'hui on vous interroge forcément
sur le sujet de la retraite est en fait
la problématique est souvent dans nos
sociétés c'est le problème c'est qu'en
fait la retraite c'est un une partie du
sujet et seul vous ne pouvez pas
d'adressé le vrai sujet derrière la
notion de retraite c'est la notion
revenus la nation niveau de vie est la
question qui se pose lorsqu'on parle des
retraites ses limites - le niveau de vie
des seniors actuels et vous avez raison
le traitement des retraités aujourd'hui
en france est remarquable il est
généreux simon les mots lorsqu'on
compare partout ailleurs en fait il est
généreux lorsque vous regardez sur le
doute pardon c'est de subornation votre
nom je crois que c'est l'héritage en
fait d'un modèle qui étaient conçus à
une autre époque et simplement que ce
modèle là on a eu les moyens en fête de
l'eau entre guillemets d'assumer ce
niveau de vie il faut l'assumer et donc
la notion fait de faire baisser les
retraites des gens qui sont à la
retraite c'est vrai que ça paraît en
fait on change pas en fait les gérer les
clauses du contrat en cours de route
donc c'est comme ça on avait on a un
système généraux on a vu un système
généreux tant mieux voilà donc après il
est forcément un peu coûteux pour la
population active il est un peu plus
coûteux qu'ailleurs c'est vrai voilà
mais bon ça c'est notre modèle de
société la question fondamentale est pas
celle des retraités d'aujourd'hui la
question c'est celle du niveau de vie
des seniors demain et c'est là où moi je
m'interroge il qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé sur ces sujets là et je pense
en réalité qu'il est vain d'essayer de
répondre à la notion des niveaux de vie
des seniors demain uniquement à travers
le prisme des retraites parce que c'est
là où peut-être qu'on pourrait apprendre
les notions de lunettes roses c'est que
l'évolution de la démographie et les
incertitudes qu'on a sur les projections
en termes de masse salariale et la
projection en termes de croissance font
qu' il est évident en fait il ya trois
manières en fait de de rétablir les
équilibres dans un modèle de régime des
retraites c'est lorsqu'on a entraîné
plus de prestations versus pas plus de
cotisations encaissées c'est soit on
augmente l'âge de départ à la retraite
bon il ya un plafond
sur non mais c'est évident qu'on peut
pas se cacher derrière son petit doigt
et d'une certaine manière c'est déjà
fait tous les mets d'ailleurs toutes les
réformes des retraites amène en fait un
logement à nos logements en fait de
l'âge de départ à la retraite en tout
cas volontaire puisque en fait les gens
rentrent rentrer dans le marché du
travail en fait plus de gens vivent que
par le passé et grosso modo s'ils
veulent toucher leur retraite à taux
plein on m'a fait doivent travailler
plus longtemps ça c'est le premier point
il ya l'âge il ya les taux de cotisation
on va pas déshabiller paul pour habiller
jacques concrètement ceux qui disent
qu'on peut équilibrer les modèles à
travers l'augmentation des taux de
cotisations que ce soient sur les
salariés ou les entreprises vivent sur
notre monde sur notre planète à dire que
ni l'une ni l'autre je parle pas des
grandes entreprises du cac 40 qui font
souvent en fait le pire il la une des
journaux mais grosso modo nos
entreprises il est essentielle aux
entreprises en france ne sont pas
capables de supporter des taux de
cotisations plus élevées qu'aujourd'hui
ni même en fait les salariés en tant que
tel donc imaginer que ça soit un levier
qu'on puisse mobiliser pour récupérer
kevin j'irai lui le régime de retraite à
terme sa part est en fait doute le
troisième point c'est le niveau des
pensions mes invités niveau des pensions
si leur maul la baisse relative des
pensions de retraite et la réalité c'est
que nous ne pouvons pas passer outre
d'ailleurs la notion d' augmentation de
l'âge de départ à la retraite amène à
une baisse relative des pensions de
retraite concrètement et c'est
obligatoire hérault gard en fait des des
rapports de force entre entre les
populations les classes d'âge en fait
dans notre pays à mon sens c'est un
débat vain d'essayer de faire croire
qu'on ne devra pas mobiliser et à la
fois l'âge de départ à la retraite et où
en fait les pins le niveau des pensions
relative de retraite donc la question
fondamentale c'est pas celle ci c'est
acté le fait arrêtons de nous cacher
derrière notre petit doigt que les
pensions de retraite pour les seniors de
demain ceux de 2030 seront moins élevés
relativement en fait au niveau actuel
que pour les seniors d'aujourd'hui à
partir de là soit on le constate on ne
fait rien on dit que rien ne va se
passer donc d'une certaine manière on
appauvrit ces populations à terme soit
on se pose la question des leviers dans
une société pour maintenir le niveau de
vie de ces gens qui auront de fait des
transferts sociaux qui sera moins élevé
demain qu'aujourd'hui en proportion et
donc c'est ça le vrai sujet le vrai
sujet des retraites c'est bien sûr avoir
un mécanisme le plus équilibré possible
mais je reviendrai tout à l'heure sur le
fait qu' investir sur le long terme
c'est bien mais là où medi 30 %
d'actions 30 % d'actions je m'interroge
et c'est mon métier par ailleurs en fait
d'être aussi sûres dans le secteur
financier quand vous avez une banque
centrale aujourd'hui qui ai mis des
tombereaux d'argent qu'est ce que c'est
le prix qu'est ce que serait la valeur
alors bien sûr on est obligé d'être
dedans mais qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça
vous concrètement aujourd'hui en fait on
est on vit dans un monde dans lequel les
prix des actifs financiers sont quasi
administrés alors tant mieux parce que
ça les fait monter mais demain en fait
on ne connaît pas justement les la
résilience en fait de ces comportements
l'évolution de la valeur parce que la
valeur c'est une question philosophique
abandonné c'est quelqu'un qui veut
acheter versus quelqu'un qui veut vendre
et celui qui doit acheter il doit aussi
avoir en fait l'argent pour pouvoir en
fait concrétiser cette envie d'acheter
en acte concret donc déjà en fait il ya
ce premier point donc à mon sens le vrai
sujet c'est celui en fait j'ai levier
qui existent pour assurer un niveau de
vie confortable aux seniors de demain
parce qu imaginer qu'on puisse le faire
qu'à travers le prisme des retraites et
20 voire même si on voulait être
provocant et probablement un mensonge
donc après derrière on peut discuter en
fait de ce qui reste il reste pour le
manque trois choses virez le travail
mais pas le travail forcé entre
guillemets dire que face en fait une
baisse des pensions des pensions des
seniors pour les pensions pour les
pardon pour les seniors de demain les
gens auront envie de compléter leurs
revenus donc il va y avoir en fait une
envie de travailler en fête ou de
continuer à travailler pour compléter
ses revenus issus des pensions de
retraite premièrement soit vous avez les
revenus financiers voilà donc voilà
aussi on peut s'interroger est ce que
ben tous les produits d'épargné bien
mais est-ce qu'il faut les laisser faut
autoriser les sorties en capital ce qui
vaut pas plutôt allé vers des systèmes
d'assurance à savoir des rentes viagères
en fait qui permettrait de s'assurer les
gens disposeront fait de niveaux de vie
qu'ils seront suffisants jusqu'à la fin
le troisième est le troisième levier en
fait il est simple c'est celui de la
solidarité si les niveaux de vie sont
amenés à diminuer et bien est ce que la
société souhaite mettre en place les
mécanismes de solidarité qu'ils sont de
deux ordres soient collectifs mais la
solidarité collective elle veut dire
argent donc est-ce qu'on en aura les
moyens soient maintes rafa milian comme
l'a toujours fait lorsqu en fait on est
amené à voir des générations du dessus
qui sont en situation en fait un peu
plus difficile ou qui n'ont pas assez
pour subvenir à leurs besoins eh bien on
met en place des mécanismes de
solidarité intra familiales et quand
vous tirez le fil de ces sujets qui
seront forcément il y aura un peu des
trois il y aura du travail il y aura des
revenus des capitaux il y aura aussi de
la solidaire et à implémenter on regarde
une contre gaming du tsunami
démographique qui vient vers nous et
c'est tant mieux parce que le tsunami
des graphiques on parle de nos parents
des grands-parents pour certains départs
en fait pour d'autres et donc le levier
principal c'est aujourd'hui est ce que
notre société est prête à faire face
avec l'explosion du besoin d'être qui
vient est ce qu'elle est prête ou est ce
qu elle s'est organisée pour mettre en
place des mécanismes de solidarité
collective certes mais aussi en fait
intrafamiliales à savoir est ce que
demain dimanche chacune de nos familles
nous serons en mesure de mettre en place
des mécanismes de solidarité intra
familiales qui ne passeront pas
forcément par chéquier qui passeront par
sow qui s'occupait d'eux ou avoir en
fait l'aller être à proximité ou d'une
proximité suffisamment forte avec la
génération du dessus pour pouvoir en
fait remplir cette mission essentielle
qui est celle du besoin d aide françois
xavier alors peut-être plusieurs
prédisent un point qui est important on
a parlé de toute base de vie relatif
pardon je jette taquin c1 ce concept
d'économistes les pourquoi je dis ça
parce que les grands publics et où le
grand public a retenu baisse de tout le
baisse du taux de remplacement aux
dimensions réelles ont dit les deux les
pensions vont baisser les retraites ne
vont pas baisser je pense que c'est pour
ça que pour moi le terme de relative la
cjr relative mais maintenant je sais ça
pourquoi parce que c'est le touche pas
non mais c'est le jeu pense que c'est le
jeu j'insiste dessus parce que ces
sources d'une incompréhension majeur
on a appliqué on applique en grand en
population générale comme on dit un
concept économique et la notion du taux
de remplacement ou du baisse du niveau
de vie relatif et nos concitoyens ont
compris que c'était une baisse du niveau
des retraites une baisse des valeurs
traite en valeur absolue c'est pas le
sujet pourquoi je dis ça parce que les
personnes qui arrivent en retraite
actuellement il ya demain ils ont des
carriers complète ce qui n'était pas le
cas de leurs prédécesseurs c'est
notamment le cas des dames je prends un
exemple tout simple quand vous prenez
aujourd'hui aux mômes dans libre dans
l'ue stone dont j'admire dans les
retraités actuels beaucoup de dames sont
partis avec des niveaux très faibles
parce qu'elle n'avait pas les cas la
complète les dames qui partent en
retraite aujourd'hui et demain ils ont
le même niveau d'étude que les garçons
ils ont de plus en plus car on peut être
pas notamment le même niveau de
rémunération mais de plus en plus des
claires et complètes donc si je raisonne
du point de vue du niveau des retraites
des dames qui vont liquide et qui vont
partir entrer dans les dix ans à venir
leur niveau en tant que le niveau de
retraite va être supérieur à celui de la
génération précédente parce qu'elles
auront une carrière complète sur le
marché du travail parce qu'ils ont oui
mais ça c'est la vrai il y à briey le
débat des conditions de réversion mais
ce que je vois pas là ça c'est un autre
sujet d'un autre jamais tout cas en tant
qu' en tant que dames grèce des écarts
mais quand je prends sur sur 20 ans le
niveau de vie des retraites des femmes a
progressé parce que c'est là où je vous
rejoins la retraite c'est le reflet de
ces le rejet de marché du travail mais
déjà ça c'est un élément qui est central
parce que de passer du principe
économique un concept individuel pour
chacun d'entre nous c'est pour ça qu'en
jeu ok tout à l'heure le simulateur les
traduire en euros pour vous pour moi
pour chacun d'entre nous étant donné
notre parcours professionnel étant donné
nos choix de vie qu'est ce que ça donne
parce que là on passe d'un concept à un
élément concret premier pas deuxième
élément il ya la question du patrimoine
est un élément l'autre point dans le
débat mais finalement économie va on va
dire revenus enfin le régime de retraite
en répartition revenus financiers
moi si j'étais elle si je voulais faire
encore un peu de publicité
c'est quoi le taux de remplacer de quoi
le taux de rendement de la retraite par
répartition c'est quoi le taux de
rendement des actifs financiers et là
moi aujourd'hui quand vous cotisez un
euro hong haeran 10 5% aujourd'hui quand
je vois le taux de rencontrer une banque
centrale qui vous bien ont-ils s'annonce
et novations s'est vu notre pyramide des
âges et vous la dynamisme de l'économie
française pourquoi je dis ça je dis pas
que c'est mieux est ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que quand on raisonne sur
ces éléments là il faudrait c'est là on
touche du doigt tout à l'heure la
fragilité des revenus financiers c'est
aussi dépendants parce que 1,3080 deroff
financer sais combien vous rapportez
marchés financiers mais si vous voulez
en tirer un bon prix il faut que vous
ayez les acheteurs de vous de vos avoirs
financiers qui va vous les achetez il
faut vous ayez des jeunes aussi et on
touche là le fait que conçoit en
répartition qu'on fera en capitalisation
on est 100 on est sensible à l'économie
et à la démographie il se trouve que
nous on a beaucoup de relations avec
d'autres organismes paritaires à
l'étranger la hollande et enfin de
notamment beaucoup de roumains et des
fonds de pension hollande géré par les
partenaires sociaux au moment de la
crise de 2008 ils ont dû ils ont failli
baisser les retraites mais là on valeur
absolue parce que la contrepartie des
actifs avaient baissé et donc ce que mon
propos c'est de dire dans ces éléments
là et si on si on dit qu'on a des
éléments de fragilité économique et
démographique cette approche là elle est
commune aux deux systèmes elle est
commune aux deux systèmes et sur cette
question à cette question financière
voilà le vrai mercantilisation qu'on
soit extrêmement clair il n'est pas
meilleur mois la région et surtout à
l'ailé alors il a aussi s'il est aussi
dépendant de l'économie et la
démographie
mais je dirais même qu'il est plus
déviants
je revenais sur le débat parce que vous
avez été sur ce débat duo tony mais
politiques partisanes n'ont le choix et
non mais vraiment le choix économie
politique symptomatique et en politique
thème thomas dit non le choix de choix
nos deux pays le consensus de notre pays
ça a été de se dire on veut garantir aux
retraités mais vous c'était c'était le
débat du tout remplacement total on veut
garantir aux retraités une forme de
maintien du niveau de vie vous garantira
la masse électorale des retraités non ce
choix là ah pardon mon amant pardon et
l'argent de l'état qui veut dire si tu
vas tomber non mais ce choix là je me
fasse la localité bien sûr aimé ce show
à las il a été fait dans les années 60
et 70
quand on a que toute croissance de
m'aider mais surtout il ya beaucoup de
jeunes ne qu'on se posait pas on n'était
pas dans un débat politicien partisan
quand on a
généralisé la retraite dans le pays
généralisée l'agirc-arrco dans le pays
parce qu'au départ leur côté réagi
entreprises branches et a été généralisé
en 70 et donc la loue le choix collectif
a été de dire justement pour toutes ces
générations là ça a été un agent qui
travaille et qui en a qui ont beaucoup
travaillé qui ont été les trente
glorieuses et à qui finalement le choix
collectif a été de dire on veut garantir
une forme de maintien de pouvoir d'achat
en retraite par rapport à celui qu'on a
en activité donc c'est pour ça que je
disais qu aujourd'hui le paradoxe est
que si je me focalise sur la question du
taux de remplacement je vous aviez un
écart mais si je me focalise sur l'écart
de niveau de vie actif retraité irec
l'écart n'existe quasiment pas donc
c'est bruggink cette question là alors
c'est vrai mais la question je voulais
changer c'est celle de la mairie
le revenu même en fait effectivement
aujourd'hui des délais plus de 65 ans
ont fait des retraités on l'évalué à peu
près un peu plus de 100 % du revenu net
médian des 20 65 ans vous avez raison
c'est dire qu'effectivement aujourd'hui
il ya un traitement généreux mais
attention on dirait que c'est pas moi je
vois qu'il est généreux pourquoi il
déjeune europe on part toujours rien par
rapport aux autres c'est à dire que vous
regardez les pays de nos cd on avait 87
% dans les pays de l'union européenne on
à 91 il ya nous on est à 100 un super la
question fondamentale c'est qu'il
faudrait pas être la grenouille dans
dans la casserole avec l'eau et que le
feu monde en sort salit tommy je veux
pas faire peur et c'est important de le
débat ne veut pas dire que les pensions
de retraites vont baisser dirk
relativement le taux de remplacement
savoir ce que vous aurez à la retraite
issue en fait de vos régimes de retraite
versus que vous gagnez la dernière année
dans fait de votre boulot sera
probablement plus faible que les
générations qui précède ça veut pas dire
vous gagnerez - mais faut quand même pas
avoir peur des mots parce qu'à force de
ne pas dire la réalité de manière crue
d'une certaine manière on ne pousse pas
nos sociétés à se réinventer à savoir qu
en parle parce que le sujet en fait
c'est bien beau de dire que en primaire
on ne va rien faire mais concrètement
campagne de solidarité intra familiales
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a concentré
l'activité en gros les jeunes sans coûts
donc là c'est hyper intéressant de
regarder la démographie c'est que c'est
un gros mot en fait c'est un truc
général mais lorsqu'on regarde dans le
détail les jeunes ceux qui travaillent
sont plus ils sont contraints centré
essentiellement dans les zones
métropolitaines les métropoles
régionales la capitale et aujourd'hui
les seniors ils sont ils sont en tout
les tours et hu a reculé hier qu'à une
société a pas compris qu'on aura besoin
de mobiliser la solidarité intra
familiales pour faire face aux besoins
des deux qu'il faudra apporter à nos
générations du dessus et bien
concrètement comment vous faites comment
on fait vous prenez votre bagnole ou
fait 3h ou 4h de route pour aller les
aider dire que si collectivement n'a pas
conscience qu'il faut mobiliser les
conditions pour mettre en place la
solidaire et intrafamiliale ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut que la
société s'organise pour relocaliser
aussi des emplois là où on a des bassins
de seniors dire qu'il faut en fait
mettre en place une dynamique en tout
cas une vision géographie de
distribution d'emplois sur l'ensemble du
territoire parce que ça posera les
jalons serein de gérer vous faites une
société qui vit avec des problèmes
éthiques de des brutes des dépendances
qui vont exploser et avec des niveaux de
retraite qui entre guillemets en termes
relatifs baisseront par rapport au passé
et ne permettront pas d'assumer le même
niveau dit que les seniors du dessus de
la génération précédente donc c'est un
peu le sujet donc le sujet de base c'est
de se dire à force de 2,2 de faire comme
si on allait s'adapter progressivement
en fait on ne crée pas les conditions de
caen ne crée pas en fait lavigueur
suffisante où l'on ne dépense pas
l'énergie suffisante pour remettre en
question un certain nombre de mécanismes
notamment celui en fait de la
concentration des emplois aujourd'hui
donc des actifs toujours dans les mêmes
endroits et ces endroits là sont
déconnectés des seniors d'aujourd'hui et
de demain
3 trois éléments premier élément je
pense que le sujet de la faim est un
sujet majeur nous que nous on traduit
sous forme d' aide aux aidants ont dans
notre jeu c'est aussi encore un focus
sur ce qu'on fait on a mis en place des
sujets de des nausées non mais là dessus
j'ai bien compris gratuit c'est à dire
que on met en place des aides pour
permettre je dirais à d je dirais aux
français est temps que se forme de
groupes de paroles dispositif de rock de
répit enfin c'est très concret c'est
très étrange et qui lugeait si vous
passez suite c'est qu'on consacre chaque
année 300 sa rapine euros ce qu'on
appelle notre action sociale et donc
c'est pour pour tout le monde et a
tendance à dire donc là pour tous ceux
qui sont chez nous et donc c'est
quasiment tout le monde et ben ils sont
hissés ses prestations sont accessibles
et c'est trés territorialisée parce que
on sait bien qu'on ait mobile à 30
kilomètres donc faut pas donc on a on
accepte cet élément la deuxième élément
je reviens j'ai pas le sentiment qu'on
soit dans le déni en matière de retraite
j'ai le sentiment qu'on a plutôt
aujourd'hui on a plutôt le sentiment si
on faisait un micro trottoir avec nos
maisons en demander trop actif je sais
pas mais surtout c'est si on faisait un
micro-trottoir aujourd'hui le sentiment
que malheureusement un bruit de fond
n'est pas breton positif donc le message
on a un sujet collectif il est passé
troisième sujet le débat c'est un sujet
des équilibres entre les générations au
final combien c'est là tout l'enjeu et
nous on le vit un vrai je le vis en
négociation c'est au final pour piloter
un régime de retraite dans la durée quel
est le taux de contribution qu'on
demande aux actifs qu'elle écoute
conception pour demande aux entreprises
qu elles on trouve contribution qu'on
demande aux retraités et si je deviens
les actifs qu'elles sont ceux qui sont
proches de la retraite et c'est tout le
débat quand on est aussi sur la solide a
été un très violent c'est aussi le débat
de la solidarité entre les générations
c'est au final comment on fait société
ces collectifs et comment on n'oppose
pas mais quand il ya des efforts à faire
comment chaque génération contribuer à
cela parce que le débat de là et c'est
là où on est très concret sur la
solidarité européenne pour faire un mot
qui on peut en faire des actions et donc
nous quand j'évoquais tout à l'heure le
ce qu'on a fait en 2015 à tout le monde
était mis à contribution les retraités
les gens qui étaient proches de la
retraite les gens vivent là parce que
c'était un bien commun la retraite je
crois que c'est jean pierre chevènement
qui disait la retraite c'est le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
donc on est véritablement conscient que
ce bien commun la c'est pas en opposant
génération mais c'est bien en les
réunissant les fédérant les attendent en
leur disant que quand il ya des périodes
délicates tout le monde doit y
contribuer mais parce que à la fin tout
le monde est gagnant de cette démarche
je rappelle quand même que compris sur
le débat du niveau des retraites
pour ça que le débat du taux de
remplacement est complexe parce que y
compris le niveau des retraites n'a
jamais été aussi élevé il continuera à
être élevée je prends un exemple simple
y compris dans nos propres règles
allégées rao quand vous êtes au chômage
vous non
500 tango leur sentence a fait un petit
peu avec tout le respect que je vous
dois ça fait un petit peu vendeur de
moquettes pas du tout j'essaye d'être ne
pas aller dans les idées reçues parce
que je trouve que sur ces sujets là il
ya malheureusement trop d'idées reçues
ou un discours qui est alors je suis à
lille et des concours d'éloquence un
show ces non mais en l'occurrence et c
était une école qui est à cergy-pontoise
donc c'est la maison d'en face à cergy
pontoise
mais c'est pas non non ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que j'ai c'est d'être
ni dans tout va bien on y dort tout va
mal mais c'est d'avoir un discours de
vérité si vous me permettez l'expression
c'est du pragmatisme et pragmatisme et
surtout je considère que vos auditeurs
taux longs nous sommes des adultes de
responsables donc je suis pas la poisse
pardon je suis pas un bonimenteur si
j'étais un bonimenteur je serai pas à
serait pas digne de la confiance des
ménages autant changer de métier fashola
bon ma responsabilité mais bon moi j'ai
d'abord été officier de marine j'ai été
directeur d'hôpital j'étais je veux pas
mal de métier c'est mon septième acteur
de [__] qu'est ce que ça fait de
supprimer des lits vous étiez directeur
de quel hôpital j'ai été en poste en en
gestion rhône alpes dans la région rhône
alpes vous avez fait sauter comme un
devis j'ai pas fait sauter des lits et
là le problème c'est que posée par le
lycée vous et moi si on hospitalise et
demain est ce qu'on pense qu'on va pas
rentrer plus vite possible à la maison
pour être au milieu des siens vous et
moi alors vous vivait confortablement
nous on connaît beaucoup de médecins il
me titille notre on est posée médecin
donc je connais très bien mais bien son
nom il ya des médecines trop vitesse en
france
je sais pas si les médecines à trois
vitesses ce que je sais simplement vous
le savez non mais je sais vous le savez
ça il y avait un ancien directeur de la
cnam jean jacques viseur
bien ils disaient ils étaient probants
qui sent qu non il y en aurait 6
pourquoi je dis ça dans le débat le
débat et ses longs entre le débat du
territoriales pour mathilde diversion
pas du tout pas du tout le vrai débat
c'est est ce que en fond quel est mon
hockey en fonction de là où je vis
est-ce que j'ai accès de la même manière
au niveau de soins et on sait bien il en
rentre dans le débat du territoriales on
a aujourd'hui une concentration mais
pourquoi parce que les médecins ils sont
comme vous et moi ils font leurs études
dans les grandes villes et souvent ils
s'installent à proximité des grandes
villes donc c'est comment aussi on
arrive et c'est moi
on avait on avait essayé de proposer des
stages dans les zones rurales parce
qu'on sait bien court et finalement
s'installent là où on a été en stage et
là où on peut trouver un job pour le
conjoint est digne d'une école pour les
enfants et là c'est extrêmement concret
donc toute la proche c'est une approche
de service si je suis j'y reste la
position de principe je me je peux me
désole si je suis dans l'action je peux
être de résoudre des questions concrètes
c'est aussi la question de l'exercice
regroupé parce qu'on peut personne en
train de travailler tout seul on veut
travailler en équipe donc c'est comment
on favorise aussi cela vous essayez le
redis mende saint pierre l'action soeur
du rêve c'est ça l'action sort du rêve
en tout cas c'est important d'avoir un
idéal on va parler d'idéal je vais y
aurait des choses c'est l'intérêt en
réponse à on n'est pas en réponse
jusqu'ici juste pendant que notre invité
est bien chaud 30 % d'actions
investissements européens c'est quel
type d'action c'est de l'armement cdu
défense et cdu est ce que c'est des
entreprises avec une
prospective sur du long terme une
prospective sur l'écologie une
prospective sur le désarmement ou est ce
que ma retraite peut financer la vente
de chars en grèce où est ce que ma
retraite est investi par l'intermédiaire
d'une entreprise européenne qui fait de
l'évasion fiscale est-ce que vous
surveillez où mon argent mais cotisation
est investi et comment vous sur l'idée
ça qui désosse votre père votre
portefeuille d'actions je vous écoute
alors notre notre no no de réserves sont
gérées en fonction d'une de charretier
serre vg qui veut dire investissement
socialement responsable on n'est pas on
est partis du standard de places
standards de place en matière dense que
ses clients seraient ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le standard le plus qu il ya
plusieurs définitions llacer je veux pas
être au départ mais c'est rude notamment
beaucoup ces deux c'est le best in class
dans chaque classe quelle est la part
d'un vieux micros ses parents pendant
que c'est le jeu c'est le best in class
bon premier pas deuxième élément pour
gérer les 60 milliards ont fait appel
aux grands gestionnaires d'actifs de la
place c'est pas notre métier donc mais
on met régulièrement en concurrence les
grands gestionnaires d'actifs qui sont
qui sont bas que tout cause on connaît
les natixis lé amundi les bnp les je
voudrais pas si j'en oublie j'aurai je
fais des crises sévères des ténèbres
tous les grands gestionnaires d'actifs
de la place et qui sont un croc oui
blackrock a un tout petit peu il se
trouve qu'il ya quelques années on avait
mai mais très peu extrêmement peu sur
les 60 milliards justement parce que là
on a aussi une part d'actions
internationales et quand on est sur les
états unis on essaie aussi de prendre
des gestionnaires qui connaissent bien
marché domestique c'est juste une fois
tu partes actions internationales au bac
en jeu dizaine d'autres zones
domestiques d'investissement c'est la
zone euro donc c'est prague dans mon
église ou séchées de la maison voilà et
la zoé la zone domestique
d'investissement c'est hauteur c'est un
bon deux tiers c'est un bon deux tiers
de l'autre de notre de notre invité de
notre investissement mais on essaye
aussi d'aller au delà de la zone euro en
europe et en dehors de l'europe c'est
juste un sujet de diverses applications
web ça renvoie au débat des des cycles
économiques ça envoie débat destiné
connu et donc pour répondre à vos
questions ben quand on sélectionne de
gestion d'actifs quand on leur demande
de gérer notre portefeuille on leur
demande cela après je prends un exemple
très concret quand je suis sur les nerfs
vous me parlez armements airbus
a revu ses activités d'armes en or mais
a buté une grande activité des
détectives des civils et a bu ce sont
des salariés qui cotisent en france qui
travaille en france qui cotisent à
l'agirc arrco donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est dans une approche autant il ya des
jours où il n'y a pas de débat sur
l'exclusion les mines antipersonnel et
autres mais quand on est dans la proche
best in class c'est aussi l'idée de se
dire il n'ya pas il ya pas d il ya
quelques secteurs l'idée c'est d'aider à
progresser un certain nombre de secteurs
je prends l'exemple de total est-ce que
je dois exclure total par principe ou
est-ce qu'on va plutôt financer des
actions sociales via le vert donc voyez
c'est là où c'est quoi vielverge
nominale aujourd'hui total peut émettre
des greens bande voilà pour être très
clair et tout logiquement green beans
basse c'est ce sont des actions qui
peuvent financer des actions en matière
de diversifier la diversification
énergétique si des obligations est ce
que c'est un travestissement de la
langue française
non mr concrètement mais là c'est pas
sais pas vous mais oser par votre faute
mais la notion fait dié serges et
séraphin
aujourd'hui soyons sérieux évidemment en
fait une prise de conscience
collective mais aujourd'hui c'est quand
même vaste blague tout de même c'est un
concept marketing parce que lorsqu'on
regarde les critères justement
d'attribution de ces notes en réalité
elle n'exclut personne pour les exclus à
les 80 boîtes sur 1600 en europe hier
c'est aujourd'hui les crises et du
marketing alors bien évidemment les gens
sont pragmatique et rationnel la finance
va s'y mettre enfin on est en train
aujourd'hui beaucoup de sociétés qui
construisent des vrais indicateurs qui
nous permettront demain
après je sais par mon métier mais
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment en fait un
vrai travail qui est en train d'être
fait sur le sujet mais pour l'instant
les critères j'ai tout ça en fait c'est
du marketing c'est de la com c'est pour
faire bien parce que ça n'exclut pas
suffisamment il n'y a pas du tout faite
de fléchage suffisant à travers ce à
travers en fait les indicateurs qui sont
mises à disposition
donc la finance s'est mis dans et c'est
logique 1 s'est mis en fait dans le
créneau parce qu'il fallait l'être mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de critère
entre guillemets il suffisamment
contraignant pour amener véritablement à
du fléchage vers des actions qui
amènerait vers a minima pas des secteurs
d'activités qu'on jugeraient néfastes
alors là je suis d'accord avec vous là
aussi il faut quand même c'est facile en
fait de dire c'est bien c'est pas bien
mais après comment on le juge est donc
là sur la notion de juger une entreprise
uniquement parce qu'elle est une petite
partie donc c'est compliqué mais c'est
pas parce que c'est compliqué qu'on fait
pas à m'en donner en fait la société
elle a le droit aussi de faire des choix
elle droit de dire sociétalement parlant
collectivement parlant ont fait le choix
de préville ce secteur plus qu'un autre
et si c'est le cas je fais des vrais
critères qui vont permettre en fait de
faire du fléchage c'est comme le
fléchage fiscale en général en gros
c'est bien en fait de l'identifier mais
après il faut que les critères
d'attribution se suffisamment sélectif
pour que ça ait du sens aujourd'hui on a
en a pas vraiment mais là encore les
financiers sont pragmatiques d'ici un an
ou deux on va probablement voir émerger
des vrais acteurs en fait de deux le sg
ou du l'investissement socialement
responsable mais pour l'instant ça reste
un petit peu nébuleux et je connais très
bien les acteurs et qui vous travaillez
je sais à peu près en quoi ça consiste
le coin là c est ce qu on est en
statique on est ce qu'on est en
dynamique non mais c'est pourquoi je dis
ça pourquoi je dis ça vous savez je vais
prendre et j'étais le il ya récemment
que vous dites et 32 des grandes
entreprises aujourd'hui si on veut faire
venir les jeunes générations faut qu'on
ait un métier qui du sens cette question
là si vous voulez aujourd'hui recruter
les jeunes générations si vous leur
dites ah ben vous savez moi je moi je
fais que du marketing mais en fait mon
coeur le métier c'est polluer mon coeur
de métier c'est de faire n'importe quoi
comment air quand même nom m'échappe
binaire comme à l'aller on avait ce nom
mais ce que je veux dire par là tout ce
que je veux dire par là c'est on est sur
une je pense une tendance importante qui
n'est pas parfaite pour je dis qu'on est
dans une phase où aussi et nous notre
rôle c'est pas de pointer du doigt c'est
un incident et tout le monde a progressé
et c'est pour ça que je dis moi ma
responsabilité c'est compliqué pour moi
de dire
j'accepte les cotisations sociales
d'airbus mais ils sont tout ça comprenez
c'est pas parfait donc je vas pas aller
investir dans les actions là mais c'est
joli et une cohérence c'est juste la
seule cohérence voilà étant toujours
problématique surtout si vous voulez
surtout si vous voulez quand par
ailleurs on voit alors après on retrouve
et que ça va assez vite on pas de
chauffe avantage mais on voit aussi des
vraies actions sur l'avion décarboné du
futur à tous comme ça donc c'est aussi
des éléments qui sont pas voilà après
vous savez c'est tout le débat de ces
comme la question l'automobile est-ce
que abbas y est ce que dans l'automobile
on veut tous rouler en voiture
électrique quoi mais est-ce qu'on a des
batteries qui permettent de faire 500
guides raids n'ont pas d'endroit entre
temps on a dit version hybride bon est
ce que l'hybride c'est pas déjà une
première étape c'est le même sujet c'est
le même sujet donc c'est cette question
là c'est une question de escompté dans
la complexité mais on assume fondée dans
principe de réalité jallet éthique de
conviction versus éthique de
responsabilité et donc notre rôle c'est
de faire progresser tout le monde est là
et nous on effectivement dans cette
phase où étant je dirais en charge de
l'ensemble des écoles françaises et dans
une optique dédiée tout le monde a
progressé plutôt que d'exclure mais je
reconnais que il ya une part de
d'assumer une forme de 10 des ald
d'idées à l'imparfait oui par rapport à
votre question tout à l'heure oui
c'était une idée à la parfaite mais on
se revendique d'un idéal un parfait
parce que on doit le choix proposé après
concrètement est ce que tout ça ne
révèle pas tout de même alors c'est pas
typique à la france est aujourd'hui
typique en fait des économies
développées une forme de déjà un premier
concept c'est qu'on apprend une chose
dans l'entrepreneuriat puisqu'il se
trouve que ça fait c'est un chemin que
moi je suis depuis maintenant pas mal de
temps c'est que ce qu il plus dangereux
dans le business en général et aussi
dans le recrutement c'est faire une
promesse de ne pas la tenir et donc ça
sera un vrai enjeu parce que aujourd'hui
c'est facile de dire on est en fait on
fait de l'investissement socialement
responsable on avait des activités on va
donner du sens il faut faire attention
lorsqu'on met en fait une promesse au
dessus en fait de sa porte entre
guillemets à ce que la promesse soit en
réalité dans les faits réalisée dans
l'entreprise parce qu'une chose est sûre
c'est que les générations qui viennent
sont assez différentes dans nos
entreprises sont assez différentes des
générations précédentes même pour les
jeunes elle était assez légitimistes
aujourd'hui elles en ont rien à faire
mon concrètement si elle voit une
déconnexion entre ce qui est affiché et
communiquer et la réalité des faits elle
ne restera pas donc d'une certaine
manière darwin va faire probablement son
effet et à terme des boîtes qui font des
promesses mais ne met pas en adéquation
la parole aux actes mais concrètement
seront amenés à souffrir et ça c'est une
bonne chose alors c'est sûr que ça sera
pas tout de suite mais voilà donc c'est
un jeu dangereux d'aller sur le terrain
du bon du bien
lorsque en réalité on n'est pas
complètement
parfaitement en adéquation premièrement
deuxièmement mais c'est un exercice
impossible pour monsieur pour lui
demander en fait son avis sur
l'assainissement socialement responsable
c'est quand même bien la france c'est à
dire que en fait aussi qu'elle et son
mandat quel est le mandat de
l'agirc-arrco communiquer c'est financer
le régime des retraites concrètement en
fait ils devraient pas avoir le choix
concrètement soit collectivement 10 et
finançait régime des retraites est au
dessus on a des règles d'application
gérer ou 2 ou de choix ou de critères
qui me sont imposés par la société donc
par le politique et je les applique mais
en fait laissé libre cours à chacun où à
chaque action ou à chaque entreprise de
définir son propre sa propre
responsabilité d'une certaine manière
vous les méthodes à une situation
impossible
concrètement quand vous faites c'est
concret il nous fait de la gestion sous
mandat vous avez de l'argent gérer
donner à des investisseurs pour qu'ils
investissent c'est vrai chacun son
métier donc c'est bien de laisser à des
professionnels mais après elle et
interagir avec les gens à qui vous avez
confié la gestion en leur donnant des
critères et sert à ça d'avoir forcément
la capacité à juger en fait de la
qualité en fait de l'exercice c'est un
exercice impossible c'est en gros une
forme d'hypocrisie mondaine qui vient
qui vient de dire mais c'est pas vous
vraiment c'est pas vous du tout possible
hier c'est concrètement collectivement
on est bon on se baigne voilà où on est
baigné dans une forme d'hypocrisie
mondaine qui voudrait en fait qu'on
adresse le sujet le sujet il est
collectif il est sociétal il est
politique c'est un sujet que
collectivement nous devons adresser donc
nous éditons des règles claires pour
l'ensemble des acteurs soient
concrètement on décide que on ne le fait
pas mais il faut pas la demi-mesure dans
ce type de domaine elle est même
dangereuse parce que nous avons une
responsabilité une responsable lorsqu'on
adresse ce type de sujets sont des
sujets sérieux nous avons la
responsabilité en fait de crédibiliser
en fait notre volonté de faire avancer
notre société notamment vis-à-vis des
jeunes générations qui aujourd'hui sont
déconnectés
non mais c'est concret et donc d'une
seat ses responsabilités a poussé il
doit nous pousser à ne pas manipuler des
concepts avec trop de légèreté pour moi
on est d'accord sur l'objectif c'est le
moyen en france parlant je te provoque
là tout de suite c'est l'état qui doit
réglementer non non mais je joue
volontairement choisi j'en parlerai
après ben non non mais ces matériels à
nation à l'appel logé par la
décentralisation justin amazon ont mis
non non mais j'ai pas eu d'occasion le
développer nous on est comme on est
piloté par les partenaires sociaux
partenaires sociaux et les organisations
syndicales et patronales qui ont une
forme de légitimité dans notre pays qui
porte une part du bien commun c'est très
bien voilà et donc l'état n'a pas le
monopole de l'intérêt général et je
pense que c'est même une chance pour
notre pays si on veut que notre pays
s'en sort plus des acteurs
intermédiaires portant une part du bien
commun du coup de la situation actuelle
de la jetro grève mais je peux en dire
mais
je pense qu'il n'y a qu'en france qu'on
pense que comme par rapport à d'autres
pays que l'état l'aurait le monopole de
l'intérêt général et que tous les autres
seraient renvoyés des intérêts
particuliers et catégoriels égoïstes
nous notre expérience c'est que les
partenaires sociaux dans notre secteur
sont imposables depuis 70 ans ont pris
leurs responsabilités et donc porte une
part du bien commun du pays ils ont
adopté une définition propre lesjak a
kobe qui est inspiré des grands on n'a
pas inventé un truc dans son coin sur ce
qui peut exister lee et sert et comment
on le met en place après c'est un sujet
qui est sans fond on remet sur le métier
on serait dans d'autres pays
hier le suis pas sûr que la définition
lié serre aux etats-unis en allemagne
soit un sujet unique moi j'ai tendance à
dire je pense qu'on est typiquement sur
un sujet qui est en cours qui encore
construction il ya plusieurs écoles dans
les serres pour ce que disait tout à
l'heure best-in-class et dans chaque
classe on considère que c'est des
meilleurs de la classe ou au contraire
un meilleur dans l'univers
d'investissement en arrière on pourrait
passer des heures et des heures là
dessus nous ce qu'on souhaite adresser
comme message pour répondre à votre
question et c'est là où je suis je pense
que y compris moi dans ma fonction de
quand je recrute déjà si ce que je leur
racontais il ne le vivais pas il
resterait pas oui bombe à l'image que
les jeunes ça dépend de la rémunération
ça dépend leur qualification en poche
est bas ça va ça peut aller de pour des
jeunes qui sortent ça dépend voulait
dire alors juste après non mais je moi
que tu en es moi je moi sans des mois
j'ose d'une part moi je joue je suis
content parce que souvent l'image de la
frette ces mots tu as je dois parfois
c'est un peu ringard vaut pas y aller
moi je compte nous présente j on est un
bon compromis entre la banque d'affaires
et l'humanitaire volontairement je
prends les bons coups en instiguant
l'acte vous fait penser à quoi c'est la
question de tous qui transparence non
séparation des banques d'affairé oui
c'est sûr c'est un autre rappelez moi ce
que vous faites dans nos lits mais ça
c'est ça c'est la réglementation
américaine ce n'est pas mon sujet
norbi donc pour répondre aux six mois si
vous les ayez à vous avez raison il
encore mieux combien vous dire quand il
passe ça va ça peut aller de jeu pas de
2002-2003 mai 504000 mes limites oui
mais oui mais ça dépend ça nippon du
niveau de raid de niveau de
qualification si j'ai quelqu'un qu'à
trois ans ou 5 ans d'expérience j'ai
quotidien qui soir d'école j'ai pas de
cheveux mais c'est comme si vous me
disiez n'importe qui vous combien vous
recrutez vos collaborateurs ça va
dépendre de votre rémunération c'est
bien d'essayer
qu'aucun c'est bien mais ça aurait dû
sortir le gibolin ce soit
pour présenter nos pour maintenant je
terminais dessus puisque je pense que
dans snow notre société ce qui est vrai
c'est que s'il ya un décalage de n'y a
plus d'autorité légitime en soi s'il ya
un décalage entre ce qu'on racontait ce
qu'on vit c'est perçu comme
insupportable c'est perçu comme
insupportable dans le discours est perçu
comme insupportable aussi vis-à-vis des
collaborateurs si moi même oui moi j'ai
dû porter un plan d'économies de 600
millions d'euros si moi même dans mon
comportement individuel oui parce que là
encore contribution au coût de moins
cher en gestion pour ramener l'équilibré
je suis d'accord si moi même je ne cache
un quart n'est pas cela qui moi même
dans mon comportement dans mes habitudes
et autres jeunes incarné pas cela
commence très légitime ces salles
éléments et là on touche du doigt le g
précédemment une responsabilité morale
je peut proclamer des principes mais si
je ne les porte pas si mes équipes ne
les porte pas je peux vous diriez
conférence dans le système de retraite
mais si dans les actions concrètes les
français n'ont pas de raison d'avoir
confiance eh bien il ya un écart majeur
je n'ai pas eu l'occasion développer
mais nous on s'est posé la question
comment on peut être utile aux jeunes je
veux raconter d'histoire soit retraite
et puis je peux leur être utile de
manière concrète on a pris les jeunes
dès le collège et donc au collège pas si
vous le savez en fin de 3e vous devez
faire un stage en entreprise et ben non
c'est dit voilà comment on peut leur
être utile chaque année on propose mille
stage aux élèves de troisième quand vous
n'avez pas de réseau familial c'est
compliqué de trouver un stage et là on
leur fait découvrir système de retraite
de l'intérieur les métiers de la
retraite ils touchent du doigt ce que
c'est que la solidarité entre les
générations ils peuvent comprendre
pourquoi j'ai la retraite de leurs
grands-parents existe nous toucher les
métiers aussi est donc là on est dans un
élément destiné à chaque âge d'être
concret aussi une autre challenge parce
qu'ils nous renvoient aussi compris dans
notre manière de fonctionner mais fait
du mentorat à verser quand on était en
train de diffuser des tablettes voilà
donc mon propos derrière c'est une forme
de pour mériter la confiance il faut
arriver à pouvoir le traduire ici et
maintenant pour vous pour moi et c'est
cette capacité à répondre à la question
individuelle c'est la condition est dans
l'instant c'est la condition de la
confiance dans le collectif et dans
l'avenir et c'est là où je pense monstre
on se réunit que si je t'ai que dans la
déco que dans l'incantation jusqu'à hors
sol si j'essaie de dole incarner aussi
un parfaitement que ce soit là c'est
peut-être ça peut être une première
étape pour consolider la confiance mais
effectivement dans ma capacité à
adresser
quand on est client pendant 70 ans
qu'est ce que je peux vous apporter
comme service pendant 70 ans et c'est ça
ma question parce que ça c'est un des
éléments pour consolider la confiance
d'un portefeuille clients orange non je
plaisante non je plaisante concrètement
c'est intéressant parce que attention
tout à l'heure ce que sur la notion 10
et sert justement je veux pas du tout
c'est pas vous que j'ai pointé du doigt
c'est plutôt en fait un secteur
d'activité avec une forme de cynisme qui
est régulier et qui est courant qui
amène en fait à s'engouffrer dans des
concepts marketing qui sont vendeurs
sans forcément en faire une réalité
c'est pas votre cas il n'y a pas de
soucis deuxièmement j'ai pas prononcer
la notion d'état mais deux collectifs et
vous avez raison il ya plein de manières
de faire du collectif prendre une
décision collectivement parlant sur la
notion des secteurs d'activité ou des
types d'entreprises qu'on veut qu'on
veut aider entre guillemets à progresser
le collectif ça peut se faire de plein
de manières différentes et vous avez
raison là aussi en france
malheureusement depuis trop longtemps en
une vision centralisatrice des choses
une vision descendante l'état frais tous
n'ont pas du tout au contraire votre
organisme le fait d'avoir dirigé par des
partenaires sociaux c'est une très bonne
chose il faut le redire c'est une bonne
chose et ça amène aussi à casser une
idée reçue parce que souvent fait
malheureusement les régimes de retraite
sont pointés du doigt la réalité c'est
que les coûts de gestion dans vos
organisations en fait on est vite et
sont souvent moins élevé que dans le
privé donc plutôt applaudissons dit dès
demain en tout cas ça ne coûte pas plus
cher que si c'était fait en fait par des
organismes enfants et me priver donc ça
c'est quand même une bonne chose et il
faut vous rendre hommage sur ce plan là
donc c'est vraiment plus le secteur
financier dans son ensemble et le fait
d'avoir des partenaires sociaux qui vous
apporte un ancrage et c'est comme ça
aussi qu'on peut définir collective si
je peux me permettre derrière la notion
de collectif allait crucial elle revient
en fait à la notion fait de qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure sur la notion en
fait des dents m'intéresse beaucoup
quand vous dites il faut pas opposer si
je peux me permettre on peut revenir sur
le sujet des retraites et des seniors
parce que c'est un sujet tellement
d'avenir qu'il importe en fait qu'on s'y
attarde au parler des aidants est là
aussi et des actions concrètes qu'on
doit faire pour rassembler les
générations bien évidemment il faut
arrêter de stigmatiser
on a fait des ghettos dans tous les
ghettos sociaux des ghettos
géographiques et des métropoles il ya de
la réalité des ghettos sociaux il ya des
cadres il ya tout le reste des ghettos
géographique voilà donc où il aimait les
métropoles la ruralité je vais déjà dit
on fait aussi des ghettos démographique
à savoir en fait il ya les retraités
qu'on pointe du doigt et les actifs qui
travaillent et d'une certaine manière
alors que tout retraité a été actif au
préalable et tout acte il deviendra
retraités et donc effectivement il faut
pas faire cela mais pour quand lorsque
vous évoquez les notions d'actions
concrètes pour rassembler les
générations
il ya plusieurs sujets qui sont vraiment
intéressants tout à l'heure vous parliez
de soutien aux aidants mais en boxe dans
du velours qui c'est qui est dans le
france les jeunes retraités
60 65 75 pourquoi parce que hein vous
n'avez pas besoin de bosser puisque déjà
vous êtes ici vous êtes vous êtes assis
sur un régime de retraite qui grosso
modo vous amène à voir des pension
suffisante pour maintenir votre niveau
de vie premièrement quand vous avez du
temps de vous est encore bonne santé
parce que l'espérance de vie augmente la
question fondamentale derrière
l'espérance de vie c'est plutôt
l'expérience de 800 handicapés celles ci
elles augmentent moins tout de même donc
d'une certaine manière avant 75 ans vous
êtes en forme vous avez le loisir en
fait de bouger donc vous êtes en
capacité en fait d'implémenter
les mécanismes de solidarité intra
familiales à savoir dd on vit quelle
période actuellement en ville explosion
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
des cohortes des dents dans nos sociétés
parce que l'avantagé du baby boom c'est
qu'avant d'avoir plus de 75 ans et genre
ont entre 60 et 75 donc là en ce moment
même on est en train en fait de vivre
avec une cohorte des dents qui n'a
jamais été aussi nombreuses avec une
cohorte de gens à et décidèrent de gens
de plus de 75 ans parce que
malheureusement le handicap il arrive
après 75 ans qui n'a pas encore augmenté
concrètement beaucoup d'aidants pas
beaucoup de personnes à aider c'est
toujours trop mais y en a pas beaucoup
là on board et en oeuvre lourde
maintenant moi je vous pose la question
à partir de 2021 les 60 75 ont passé du
côté des plus de 75 j'espère qu'il y
aura plus du handicap mais bon là pour
le coup en terme de prospective si on
parie que je ne ferais pas dans
concrètement va voir l' explosion du
besoin d'être des plus de 75 ans avec
des 60 des 60 75 ans qui n'augmenteront
plus renoncer dire qu'il va y avoir plus
de besoins dead pour pas forcément plus
des dents et en plus avec la
problématique de leurs revenus de leur
niveau avec des 65 60 75 ans qui auront
maintenant progressivement à adresser la
problématique de complément de revenu
vers leurs propres problématiques à eux
donc là faut être très concret justement
si on veut pas manipuler en fait des
concepts là c'est concret dire que
jusqu'à maintenant la première phase du
baby boom c'est des retraités en forme
et qui gagnent de l'argent pas beaucoup
de gens et dès demain il y aura plus de
gens aider ces gens là n'augmenteront
pas et en plus leurs revenus de demain
seront entre guillemets moins important
relativement parlant que quand je ne
connais génération précédente dont la
question concrète et là c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait collectivement pour mettre en
place en fait les mécanismes qui
permettront de répondre aux besoins des
deux qui va exploser dans notre pays
donc là je repose la question alors
individuellement c'est bien en fait
qu'on mette en place un certain nombre
de choses mais là la notion de sait qui
c'est qui va qui va s'en occuper
plusieurs plusieurs éléments sinon je
pense qu'on a devant nous un
accroissement de la part du
vieillissement là ce que vous avez avant
le même si je il faut se méfier des
critères d'âge parce que à 75 ans
aujourd'hui on est dans une meilleure
forme qu'on était ya 15 ans
dit que vous aviez vous vous avez bossé
pendant 40 ans ferai ce que je veux dire
vous êtes infirmier des choses de la
part de la part des ouvriers dans le
camp vous prenez quand même ce qu'on
appelle l'espérance de vie sans
incapacité
même si elles progressent moins vite
elle continue à progresser et pourquoi
pas ce que parce que on a quand même
même même quand les ouvriers quand vous
prenez par exemple le temps semble
activités les conditions on a amélioré
les conditions de travail c'est pas
parfait mais vous avez quand même un
élément qui est qui fait que les choses
sont moins mauvaises que celles
formulées comme ça que ce qu'on a pu
connaître et donc on a une progression
l'espérance de vie sans incapacité
premier point deuxième point vous le
voyez matière domicile aujourd'hui c'est
là tout le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
demande sociale c'est plus de leur
maison entre ces deux on y arrive c'est
de rester chez soi le plus longtemps
possible au milieu des siens et on
revient sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure et sans celui sur l'identité
viala qui traîne non non après non le
débat qu'on a le vrai débat mais là vous
toucher vous de juger là sur ces
questions là il faut toujours être aux
commandes est prudent mois de mai -
l'attitude de l'insee d'yves qu'au final
on est mobile de 30 km qu'à la fin
duquel afin d'être dans une vie
professionnelle on peut bouger ou du
mobile de 30 km de l'adour uppa 1
combien le litre de gasoil
basse et d'accès est quoi un euro 30,1
euros 40 mais c'est pas non mais c'est
pas 250 km ce que je veux dire par là ça
coûte un match j'ai combien ça coûte aux
tic et des trous combien ça coûte un
ticket de métro si vous prenez bref si
moi je les achète par dix donc ça doit
coûter 1 euro 80 une carte de famille
nous ben moi j'ai pas de carte famille
nombreuse jeu mais je prends un pass
navigo 74 euros le prix de la baguette
mal prix de la baguette si ça dépend si
vous l'achetez on peut la voir aller des
90 centimes le fonds garanti lité vos
bouquins il est provisionnée à hauteur
de combien le fonds de garantie de
dépôts bancaires des dépôts bancaires
c'est quoi c'est entre 9 et 11%
ses provisions
on est passé à questions pour un
champion
on est passé ou bien sûr et bien sûr en
garantie des dépôts bancaires les
provisionner autant de combats and mr
obama pour moi c'est au terme de
pourcentage à envoyer au niveau de fonds
propres que les banques doivent détenir
pour les 23 c'est ça bardon exactement
et c'était ça renvoyé pour moi de
mémoire les taux les taux de les taux de
fonds propres affichés par les banques
françaises de mémoire était autour de
10% ça que j'avais à l'esprit et mais
concrètement on aurait le fonds de
garantie des dépôts bancaires y sert à
quelque chose vous pensez y sert de
mémoire il était mis en place par le
gouvernement si combien coup bien sûr
les mémoires je crois que c'était 100
mille euros par part individus je crois
de mémoire et ça me faisait à baisser un
petit peu non
vraiment il tape à 70 milles mais je
repassais 1,72 me met d'accord et il
l'effet de levier qui étaient déployées
derrière c'est combien c'est à dire
l'effet de levier en fait comme le fonds
de garantie des dépôts bancaires est
provisionné courait comme ce que j'ai à
peu près dans ma poche pour garantir sa
grange rêve
sa garantie à peu près quoi 100000
compte 100 millions 200 mille comptes ça
garantit sa nouvelle à vous renvoyer
dernière est derrière derrière notre
ministre de l'époque nous avait dit ne
vous inquiétez pas on a mis dans les
textes que le fonds de garantie des
dépôts bancaires pourraient faire un
effet de levier sur les marchés qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ça après si vous
voulez la lave ou rentrer dans un débat
passionnant c'est pas des bassins nord 6
pourquoi mais c'est un débat le débat de
mémoire le fonds de garantie des
bancaires jouent pour la question des
comptes courants et l'ici votre si vous
aussi votre épargne est investi en
assurance vie s'y est investi en
livrèrent s'y est investi en livret de
développement durable il ne joue pas
donc la question de l'effet de levier
que vous évoquez c'est un sujet de la
location de l'epargne de chacun d'entre
nous entre les différents supports
non mais alors moi je vais répondre
répondre autrement en disant que de
toute façon on s'en fout
sujet de produits un peu la même chose
pour dire je vais dire pourquoi alors
après avec les témoignages politique du
constructeur une forme de cynisme menant
au départ c'était volontaire en fait on
vit quand même dans un continent grâce
notamment un peu à la rigueur allemande
même si bien des aspects en fait on doit
pas en fait prendre des leçons fait des
allemands mais sur ce plan la rigueur
entre guillemets de la gestion
financière et monétaire est plutôt un
fort
jusqu'à ya assez peu de temps on gérer
notre politique monétaire la manière
dont on finance et les choses avec un
peu de rigueur pourquoi je dis
maintenant on s'en fout parce que
concrètement les politiques monétaires
implémentée par toutes les banques
centrales au niveau mondial y compris
maintenant par la banque centrale
européenne vous disent que badini fine
et on créera de la monnaie non des
savants en descendre dans la cave on
appris mardi billets de banque et on
vous donnera autant d'argent qu'il le
faut si besoin simplement il faut
continuer pour bien comprendre et c'est
pour ça tout à l'heure quand vous disiez
que j'ai pas voulu ou interrompent mais
sur les notions des six mois de réserve
et s'il fallait à monter à 9 mois en
irait il faudra augmenter les taux de
cotisation on fait des salariés et des
entreprises moi j'ai envie de vous dire
si vous voulez passer à neuf mois elle
est appelée en fait à l'apport de la
banque centrale européenne en ce moment
ça va marcher passe concrètement à
distribuer en fait on distribue à tout
va à travers du financement c'est dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a plus de règles on
finance tout de toutes les manières donc
après annick pourquoi pas gérer l'emploi
même rentrer dans un débat théorique
avec deux économistes qui doit dire mais
pourquoi une banque centrale en fait tu
devrais pas imprimer plus de billets de
banque
certaines l'ont fait sont à des niveaux
qui sont stratosphériques et finalement
en fait leur économie saint porte pas
plus mal la question de fond est
simplement il faut presser quelques
secondes pour expliquer en fait quels
sont les risques associés à avoir une
politique monétaire qui consiste à
imprimer beaucoup de billets de banque
sans créer plus de richesse normalement
en fait c'est quoi vous avez deux va
avoir un volume de billets de banque
qu'ils soient adossées à la richesse que
vous créez comme ça en fait une 1re
billets de banque pour correspond à une
proportion fait de la richesse que vous
avez écrit aujourd'hui on a pris
beaucoup de billets de banque la
richesse concret elles n'augmentent pas
animal puisque cette année elle a même
baissé de 10% donc à la fin des fins il
se passe quoi est ce parce que lorsqu'on
rentre dans des politiques monétaires ce
type vous fait prendre un risque marc la
valeur du billet de banque qui n'est pas
autre chose qu'un contrat de confiance
entre mois qu'ils possèdent et vous qui
allait l'accepter et contre quoi vous
allez me livrer si je suis au restaurant
par exemple nos repas du midi lorsqu'une
banque centrale est amené à en fait
avoir ce type de pratiques il faut
comprendre que ça pose un risque à terme
de perte de confiance dans la valeur du
billet de banque dans la valeur de la
monnaie ça finit souvent mal tout
simplement parce que cette fuite devant
la monnaie elle veut juste dire que si
vous êtes le restaurateur en face de moi
et que je vous paye avec des billes en
banque qui ont été tout nouvellement
créée a au bout d'un moment vous allez
dire mais qu'est ce que ça vous vous mal
n'allait pas demander un mais deux et ça
finit dans l'hyperinflation pas celles
construites celle qui correspond en fait
à la perte de valeur de la monnaie dans
laquelle vous exercez donc concrètement
la limite tout ça maintenant on n'a plus
vraiment de valeur nous sommes rentrés
dans un autre monde la vraie question
qui va se poser c'est comment allons
nous en sortir sommes-nous en capacité
d'en sortir et est ce que
raisonnablement nous essaierons d'en
sortir comme des êtres entre guillemet
responsable
ou est-ce que nous attendrons connaît
même qu'un choc exogène fasse exploser
tout ça vous fait sourire
le pur est le maître mot c'est la
confiance tout à l'heure vous propose
dans ses de la coop ou pas non le vrai
sujet c'est la confiance le vrai crochet
de la droite de la sève delà de nos
sociétés de la croissance économique
c'est la confiance ce qu'on est dans une
société de confiance dans une société de
défiance je pense que c'est là où est ce
qu'on est une société pourquoi vous vous
voyez ça trivialement genre soit blanc
soit non pas du tout non mais pour dire
que faute grave faute non c'est pas ça
non content quand tennis dire que si
j'arrête de faire confiance à mes
politique je suis forcément défiance ben
oui pourquoi pas moi mon sentiment c'est
que si je ne suis je suis dans l'un des
fiancés après bah oui alors voté il ya
la feria la face de l'autre mais on va
face nous tu sais hinault font rien ils
ep rien il est payé à rien [__] il
fait n'importe quoi et donc je jouais
quand même dubitatif par rapport à
l'action est ce que dubitative veut dire
forcément envie de fait on alors je veux
quand je veux quand je vais sur mattel
fiancée forcément défiant je renvoie au
fait une très bonne travaux académiques
c'est par yann algan sur la société de
défiance et au truc ça ressemblait un
peu soit vous êtes avec nous soit vous
êtes contrebas du tout pas du tout dans
mais mon propos c'est de dire c'était
mon propos était de dire quand on est
vous disiez mais finalement est-ce que
c'est un gadget les garanties et je
pense qu'on est là pour moi au coeur de
la croissance économique c'était d'abord
ça repose sur la confiance pour faire ça
parce qu'on est dans un phénomène de
panique c'était l'un quand le fonds de
garantie a été créé c'était avec le
rival la crise de financement de
l'époque est donc deuxième est ce que
vous devez avoir peur vous épargnant de
m'être laissé vos fonds à la banque ou
escaut compte à haute voix les retirer
c'était ça le sujet c'était ça est ce
que vous faites confiance à votre banque
oui mais surtout est-ce qu'on serait de
confiance entre nous la vraie question
est lésé bref je la monte d'un cran
comment ça s'appelle l' indice de la
peur entre les marchés ouais je n'ai
cessé mais ce n'était pas qu'un sujet
financier savez c'est tout le débat y
compris est de galles diana nist
politique électorale est ce qu on fait
confiance à vos voisins c'est pour ça
que l'une des questions majeures que
nous avons traité mais là on est tous
sur un pied d'égalité c est ce qu on
veut remettre de la confiance dans le
collectif en confiance dans l'avenir
dans et à proximité et en général vous
êtes athée la phrase de kennedy ne vous
demandez pas ce que votre pays peut
faire pour vous couper dans d'autres
pays et là je pense que c'est une
question qui est pour moi et c'est à
dire qui parce que la collection
politique et économique majeure c'est
comment dans notre pays où
malheureusement on est plutôt parfois
d'une des sociétés où les gens sont
paranoïaques où on a plus d'eau dans un
principe de d1 a priori de dubitatif je
reprends votre propos de défiance est ce
qu'on arrive à remettre de la confiance
pas dans la descente est pas dans
l'incantation pas dans le principe mais
dans des éléments concrets qui donne des
raisons et c'est comme en amour les
déclarations d'amour c'est bien les
preuves d'amour c'est mieux c'est c'est
comment on incarne la confiance pour
poursuivre je reprends micro parce que
j'aime ce sujet c'est un cerveau sujet
c'est la très beau sourire pour la
confiance il faut de la justice il faut
que m quand je vois par exemple
l'euribor ou l'euribor qui ont été
trafiqués pendant des années comme
essayer de rubans tout à fait c'est quoi
le reborn passé c'est le scénariste de
référence sur le marché monétaire c'est
l'édifice définition
heureusement on peut faire la technique
financière monsieur paul soja non en
fait le sujet en fait c'est que j'essaye
de vous titiller pour faire perdre votre
zone de confort je veux quand je veux
installer comme ça je trouve que vous
prenez trop de confiance à bâbord mais
vous avez ça ici un petit peu d'actes
erreurs mais comme mon propos ce avec
les styles elle restait dans ses formes
du militant à plein de gens d'apprendre
l'arrivée de la prendre les uns les
autres entièrement d'accord il faut
surtout échanger la justice est ce que
vous trouvez que la justice financière
est ce que est ce que la justice mais
suffisamment de moyens pour rétablir la
confiance dans son système bancaire et
monétaire quand on voit qu'il ya des
manipulations sur les marchés financiers
couvert pendant des années que tous les
acteurs financiers se sont un peu
synchroniser sur sur un certain taux
interbancaires est-ce que vous pensez
que le système de justice fait son
boulot correctement pour redonner cette
confiance il ya deux éléments il ya un
sujet de justice le colloque côté
gendarmes le voleur et puis un sujet
mais les acteurs on aime les acteurs eux
mêmes c'est quoi la colonne vertébrale
qui nous unit certes on peut mettre
davantage de jeu et on boit après
rentrer dans le débat de combien de pays
c'est pour ça qu'on est auteur est prêt
à consacrer à ces grandes fonctions
combien de consacrer à la retraite
combien de consacrer à la santé combien
de concerts aux transports à l'éducation
et ça c'est un vrai choix collectifs un
poids et puis après il ya mais mais mais
finalement ces acteurs là ils ont une
colonne vertébrale je mords c'est un peu
je me mets sur mon sens l'officier de
marine qui parle pas du tout mais je
vous disais 12h10 compris moi c'est la
question de gegants tout à l'heure vous
évoquiez la question la question de
transparence et des séparations moi la
question était souvent nous on est on
est pas soumis au contrôle du parlement
mais je me sens une responsabilité que
jack rodwell une maison de verre au sens
rendre des comptes à rendre des comptes
ça c'est des éléments qui sont c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal ça s'est bien passé
c'est pas que c'est pas maintenant
rigide si c'est légitime et bien sûr
mais moi je ne vous dis je vous donnais
ma structure de rémunération jodar si si
si les partenaires sociaux décidé de
remplir son dos des morts où je devrais
pas de difficulté ça c'est moi mais pour
moi si vous voulez la question que vous
évoquez là et pour moi c'est pas si
c'est la question j'espère que c'est pas
réservés aux officiers de marine de se
poser ces questions-là se dire mais
finalement l'impression quand même je
trouve mais je trouverais sera dommage
mais ouais mais moi je suis moins
pessimiste que vous sur la nature
humaine vous dites que je suis
pessimiste pas parce que pour moi quand
vous dites c'est ça c'est le réflexe de
l'officier de marine j'espère que c'est
vrai fait de chacun d'entre nous de se
dire comment chacun d'entre nous dans
l'exercice de sa mission peut contribuer
à quoi on renvoie la question de la
responsabilité individuelle à la
responsabilité collective peut
contribuer à incarner une forme ne sais
pas si c'est de responsabilité du
rectitude enfin c'est ce qui nous unit
quand même c'est un peu est ce qu'on
fait une société où est-ce qu'on est
dans une somme d'intérêts privés
l'objectif c'est que chacun d'entre nous
et pardon maximy son intérêt individuel
contre le collectif et c'est comme ça
qu'on a fait trois ans qu'on affaiblit
on entretient le scepticisme est la
défiance et ça comme ces petits
sceptiques et défions vous êtes vertueux
et c'est une grande qualité bravo et
c'est un jugement de leurs pages entend
effectivement je ne peux que souscrire à
mais la caution de la question de
justice ne vaut en réalité ne vous
concerne pas puisque vous êtes un acteur
vertueux la problématique des secteurs
financiers c'est que souvent il ay là il
a entre guillemets privatiser les gains
et collectiviser les pertes souvent il
ay nathan d'entre eux lui pas pris la
responsabilité de ses mauvais choix et
je pense qu'effectivement collectivement
ça à dégrader l'image globale des
secteurs financiers non pour l'ensemble
du comportement des acteurs financiers
mais pour
pour
pour l'ensemble des acteurs financiers
mais pour le comportement entre
guillemets vie sud un certain nombre
d'entre eux est là la notion de justice
elle est intéressante puisque lll pose
la question surtout de la sanction donc
effectivement gens dorment enfin voila
c'est le sait les gendarmes et les
voleurs tous les acteurs financiers où
tous les agents financiers ne sont pas
des voleurs mais comme dans toute
profession il y en a lorsqu'on a des
voleurs ont fait d'un secteur financier
entre guillemets ça fait mal et souvent
collectivement ça des conséquences entre
guillemets économiques qui sont
importants la question de la sanction
est une bonne question - d'aujourd'hui
plus du passé et là on peut s'interroger
lorsque des acteurs entre guillemets ont
triché sur ce plan on est amené à
finalement collectiviser un certain
nombre de pertes savoir en gros c'est
nous qui payons c'est donc les
concitoyens qui paye vous moi et c est
ce que c'est normal la réponse est non
est ce qu'il faut le faire bien sûr pour
éviter l'effet domino qui nous amène
entre guillemets dans le trou maintenant
est-ce qu'il faut pas entre guillemets
avoir une grille de sanctions qui font
que le voleur n'ai pas envie de voler et
ça c'est la vraie question et sur la
question de la justice la notion du
pénal devrait être posée aujourd'hui
malheureusement souvent fait dans nos
métiers dans les métiers du financier la
sanction c'est une amende mais quand
quelqu'un quand vous avez entre
guillemets beaucoup d'argent une amende
vous êtes en mesure de la payer l est
pas c'est pas suffisamment important en
tout cas elle n'est pas suffisamment
douloureuse souvent entre qui pourra
empêcher l'acte et le pénal c'est autre
chose hier que peu importe ce que vous
gagnez quand vous passez un temps en
prison les gens vous regardent pas
exactement de la même manière donc je
crois mais ça c'est le vrai pas que dans
secteur financier la notion de la
sanction elle sert à quoi elle sert à ne
pas être utilisé lasserre être
dissuasive et donc la question de fond
pour rétablir un certain nombre de voix
la notion de justice notamment dans le
secteur financier c'est s'interroger sur
la sanction qui fera que les gens
n'auront pas envie d'essayer et donc là
dessus la notion en fait de financiers
versus prison peut-être interrogé ça
c'est le premier point j'en ai un autre
mais qui voulait rebondir leur nom mais
mon propos c'est de dire mais tous sens
pas comme ça on est vraiment des
originalités pas dire ça si vous voulez
dire qu'il avait gardé un sens c'est là
où entre je pense que ce qui minent
notre société ça serait le tous pourris
dans chacun des secteurs d'activité tous
bords et à partir de de la déviance de
l'inde d'une dune août certains en
disant de jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble presse que vous et donc ça je
pense que c'est sale éléments
malheureusement moi je dis souvent je
sais pas si c'est optimiste ou
pessimiste
je pense que tous les secteurs il ya une
belle courbe de gauss une belle courbe
de gauss tia kia pas des gens qui n'y a
pas des secteurs intrinsèquement bon
d'autres secteurs sont intrinsèquement
mauvais vous avez c'est la nature
humaine dans tout ce qui est là dans
tout ce qu'elle est et donc forme d'une
chose ils savent connaissance et 15
cents pallium et bien sûr nos mariages
hallal bien sûr après il ya après on
voit un autre sujet non mais voilà donc
si c'est une forme d'humilité sur le
sujet je pense que l'être humain est ce
qu il a l être humain est humain si on
voulait faire un peu de références il y
frapper du péché originel voilà donc
pourrait voilà mais pour dire que voilà
c'est un peu des morceaux de l'autre pas
parce que vous évoquez des rencontres
débat c'est est ce que c'est le
caractère dissuasif de la bnc ça c'est
une vaste un vaste sujet parce que vous
c'est vrai dans ce domaine c'est vrai
dans tous les secteurs hnc de caraquet
est-ce que demont de monter des savates
d'avoir des sanctions est plus dans une
échelle de sanctions plus élevées est-ce
que ça un caractère dissuasif ou pas
plus élevé je dois dire que c'est un
type de 120 ans
est là et là il ya des théories très
variable sur le sujet la ch'ti gars
comme ça qu'ils envoient des au
caractère dissuasif au nom de la plante
et vous risquez quelque chose bah oui
d'être viré devant présent
et moi c'est ce que je dit pas s'ils ont
planté là c'est si vous trichez tu vaux
planche maintenant rennes en étant
présents là bas non mesdames et en
mettant des mois ce que je dis à mes
équipes alors là où c'est peut-être mon
côté officiel marine je suis responsable
6,6 sur l'aja de quoi quelque chose ne
va pas je suis responsable j'assume ma
responsabilité là où vous avez raison
c'est que si je suis pas bon mais c'est
normal mais j'en assume la
responsabilité et la responsabilité peut
être peu à l'être jusqu'à une forme de
je sais pas si c'est la sanction ultime
en tout cas il ya une version en contre
avec mon propre travail mais il ya aussi
une version 6 avait y compris vis-à-vis
de mes équipes moi je vous avais donc je
prends on est dans le contexte que vit
la responsabilité de l'employeur c'est
d'assurer la santé et la sécurité de ses
collaborateurs voilà voilà donc si vous
voulez moi ce que je dis quand on quand
je quand je dis quand on organise le
déconfinement quand on organise le
retour sur site j'ai cette
responsabilité
forte de l'employeur vive les mineurs et
donc il ça je l'assumé je ne dirais pas
que c'est voyez ça fait partie de la
fonction
juste faire un aparté c'est assez sympa
bambou jours la réalité c'est que vous
avez les moyens les moyens de l'assumer
malheureusement beaucoup de petites
entreprises je n'ai pas de doute et
direct il aurait fallu penser en fait
l'accompagnement qui permet
d'implémenter cela parce que on fait pas
tous les mêmes efforts on redoute que
j'en entends tu ne regardes ambiance je
suis je me retire aucun orgueil je
devrais je dis souvent à mes équipes
s'il y en a un qui finit en prison c'est
moi j'espère que vous mènerez des
oranges 1 voilà c'est une manière de
dire ça c'était mon côté officiel mind
il ya un moment donné c'est normal
d'assumer voilà c'est pour ça qu'il est
vertueux je passe du jeune homme je
n'irai pas sur ce terrain là parce qu'on
veut on en profite pour passer un
message aux communautés et on les
remercie de nous financer et comme vous
le remarquez on avait protégé d'une
façon correcte grâce à eux et on les
remercie du mou fournir les masques leur
tipi de nous fournir les visières de
protection le gel hydroalcoolique et
c'est grâce à eux et on les remercie
d'ailleurs donc vous parler du coc vide
juteau dit petit aparté bien non c'est
bon voyage appartenant à la grèce d'être
longue je
dois non parce que tout à l'heure aux
évoqué un concept intéressant qui est
celui de la confiance je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est beau on fait d'avoir
société de confiance versus une société
de défiance mais abandonné
kitai l'onu et le serpent le mort qui
creuse un trou il tombe hier qu'en fait
on a aussi les conséquences des actions
fait qu'on a mené jusque là entre
guillemets le scepticisme plus que la
défiance dans lequel nous vivons il est
aussi en fait une conséquence de d'un
certain nombre d'actions qui ont amené à
une forme de haine décrédibilisation
alors là où tout alors emparé de la
parole publique d'une certaine manière
et c'est pas ex nihilo c'est dire qu'on
n'est pas né comme ça du jour au
lendemain d'une société de défiance aux
sceptiques c'est le premier point le
deuxième point alors là c'est
intéressant la notion de confiance c'est
un concept mais rentrons dans les faits
maintenant une fois on est d'accord sur
le fait qu'il faut reconstruire la
confiance sur cette base là en fait
comment le reconstruire le vrai sujet
c'est comment comment fait on recrée des
remises la parole politique alors à la
notion de confiance moi j y associerez
il n'y aura pas de reconstruction de la
confiance sans proximité c'est
extrêmement clair la proximité doit être
un objectif premier c'est dire qu'il
tant qu'on n'aura pas remis de la
proximité pourquoi parce que quand vous
dites j'ai pas confiance en mon voisin
ici vous avez confiance en nos voisins
parce que vous le connaissez
je n'écrivais pas facile mais en général
ça parle à tout le monde c'est sûr vous
avez confiance à des gens que vous
connaissez et le sujet principal c'est
que pendant 40 ans et je reviens à la
notion de géographie de distribution
géographique des personnes des
personnalités qui vont à de l'activité
de l'emploi qui amène en fait à
disloquer nos territoires jusqu'à en
fait faire que les gens ne se
connaissent plus prenons un exemple très
concret tout à l'heure on parlait de la
concentration d'activités dans des
centres toujours plus resserrée paris
lyon marseille en gros les métropoles
régionales au détriment du reste il se
passe quoi tout à l'heure vous parliez
en fait des flux migratoires
associés aux 30 km je porte je le porte
en faux complet mais par rapport à ça si
on regarde et les populations de
diplômés sur les natifs des départements
qui sont les départements qu'on appelle
nos lointains construit méthodologie
pour les définir en réalité les
proportions sont colossales dire que les
gens qui partent de leur département en
fait est qu'ils sont diplômés sont très
très nombreux dans les territoires en
fait aujourd'hui dans lequel il a plus
de boulot donc temps que s'ils voulaient
reconstruire la confiance il faut de la
proximité faut que les gens se
connaissent et donc pour ça qu'est ce
qu'il faut pour que les gens restent les
jeunes veulent pas partir pour partir il
faut des revenus et donc il faut de
l'emploi et c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant parce que tout ça peut
paraître sinon on fait des concepts un
peu généraux une fois que vous avez
compris que pour reconstruire la
confiance il faut recréer de la
proximité heroes for fair société de
société c'est concret 1 c'est qu'on
partage un lieu en fait de vie communs
et bien partir de laquelle armes nous
donnons en terme de collectif en terme
de société pour relocaliser entre limite
d'entre eux qualifient dans les zones
dans lesquelles il y en a plus dans les
zones dans lesquelles on fait on a fait
partir d'emplois qualifiés en fait
depuis maintenant 30 ou 40 ans et donc
là c'est une question très concrète
c'est une question fiscale c'est une
question d'infrastructures tout à
l'heure vous évoquez dans la notion de
confiance où la notion dans la notion
dans la notion de ou dans les
problématiques que vous abordez vous
abordiez le sujet des transports le
sujet des retraites le sujet de de la
santé mais en réalité ces sujets sont
pas tout à fait en tout cas selon selon
nous en fait ne doivent pas être traités
en silos sont pas les uns à côté des
autres pourquoi ou quel sens on va
donner à l'ensemble de ces sujets là la
politique de transport elle est très
clair si vous dites je veux relocaliser
des emplois qualifiés là où il y en a
plus eh bien ça pose des jalons d'une
stratégie en terme d'infrastructures
transport parce que pour relocaliser des
emplois lui est bien le préalable savez
d'avoir des infrastructures en fait de
transport tout à l'heure vous avez aussi
les infrastructures santé parce que les
médecins veulent plus aller en fait dans
les hommes qui sans reculer et pourquoi
ils veulent plus y aller parce que
socialement parlant entre les villes
souvent en fait on aime se rapprocher
des gens qui nous ressemblent c'est
comme ça mais socialement parlant dans
ces zones rurales il ya plus classes
sociales équivalentes à fait à leur
métier donc in fine ils vont aller entre
les mille îles vont dire comme ça ils
vont pas aller s'enterrer dans des zones
dans lesquelles entre les médias pearson
qui leur semblent qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire et donc c'est pour ça que la
notion d'emploi qualifiés dans ces zones
elle est cruciale donc en termes
d'infrastructures en fait de santé
distribution géographique si on remet
d'emplois qualifiés dans ces zones là et
bien en fait ça ça a du sens et ça va
recréer en fait une impulsion qui est
qui est possible et c'est vrai on fait
dans tous les domaines dans la notion de
fiscalité juste pour être encore plus
concret pour aller plus loin une fois
vous êtes d'accord avec ça sur le fait
qu'ils aient des préalables les offres
affluent de communication c'est pareil
si vous les relocaliser en fait les
emplois qualifiés surtout plus emplois
qualifiés aujourd'hui sont beaucoup
enfin ils sont plus technophiles que par
le passé eh bien ça pose les jalons ça
pose comme condition nécessaire des
infrastructures de communication qui
sont bien distribués sur l'ensemble du
territoire et donc vous mettez du sens
derrière en fait le mot confiance parce
qu'en fait il correspond en réalité à
une notion de proximité vous est par
ailleurs est par ailleurs en plus ça
vous permet de casser les ghettos
puisqu'en 40 ou 50 ans on a construit
deux grand ghetto qui ne se parlent plus
ne se connaissent plus et qui explique
probablement une partie des 10 des
différences qu'on voit dans les votes
politiques qui sont fait maintenant
depuis pas mal de temps à savoir un
bouton social de gens qualifiés sans
chômage dans les zones très concentré la
wii à l'activité d'emplois qualifiés et
des hommes entre guillemets déclassé
socialement qui sont restés là où elle
est et parce qu entre guillemets on les
a oubliés et donc en tout cas on n'a pas
créé les conditions pour préserver de
l'emploi qualifié là où partout il
devrait y en avoir et donc si c'est
intéressant de dire qu'on veut
reconstruire la confiance mais pour
reconstruire la confiance c'est pas
juste une incantation c'est parce que
vous disiez sais pas ce que je veux dire
mais c'est que derrière ils font trop
aimé avoir une vision qui permettent de
poser ou d'identifier les moyens qui
nous permettront de reconstruire la
confiance je pense qu'on partage le
point de vue que pour redonner la
confiance que c'était mon image sur
l'amour c'est par des éléments très
concrets sur la bourse et des preuves
d'amour sur les pros des mots c'est des
bisous tout de suite
mon pied droit ou non mais mon propos
c'est effectivement je pense que là le
besoin de concret que ce soit par une
approche territoriale vous l'évoquez ou
moins évoqué l' approche en terme de
service c'est ce qui nous réunit c'est
de se dire finalement le pour construire
c'est 120 pour eux pour construire un
élément de confiance il faut que ça
s'incarne il faut que ça s'incarne gelé
dire dans la dans le par rapport aux
besoins des personnes et non leur
environnement ou de leur entourage sinon
on et doit on est dans le disque juste
dit du grand écart entre des principes
affichés ce que les personnes vivent et
ça effectivement c'est juste un des
éléments soit c est insupportable et
surtout c'est une forme de du viread de
fossés qui peut s'agrandir parce qu'en
fait on on vit des principes affichés et
puis une réalité qui n'est pas ça de la
question internet vous choisissez qui va
répondre en premier
question de gégé donc wap laissez vous
votre argent de l'euro de l'or des
crypto monnaie de l'immobilier quelle
répartition
dans les sociétés que je crée
premièrement la meilleure lutte en fait
contre la déflation l'inflation c'est
son activité quand on a la possibilité
en fait de la construire ça c'est le
premier point et deuxièmement je fais un
petit peu dans l'immobilier dans mon
village et je l'expliquant deux secondes
tout simplement parce que ça va j'ai
vite promis tout simplement parce qu'en
fait on peut aussi donner à ces
investissements fait un peu de sens
je vous explique rapidement ma vie pas
longtemps c'est promis j'habite au fin
fond de l'auvergne enfin un tout petit
village de 450 habitants mon activité
mon entreprise est à paris
une autre là bas mais peu importe et en
fait je me suis aperçu en retournant
habiter en fait dans ma localité que
finalement les ces territoires qui ont
regardé de loin en réalité pour les gens
qui veulent s'y intéresser aujourd'hui
en fait à porte ou peuvent créer en fait
des vraies opportunités tout en alliant
entre guillemets l'utilité versus en
fait la rémunération aujourd'hui
concrètement les choses comment de l'or
weave en fond de portefeuille pourquoi
pas mais concrètement combien de % pas
plus de 10% c'est enfin tu affrontes
portefeuille justement si beaucoup
louent c'est beaucoup mais bon alors ça
sert en fait de valeur refuge
traditionnelle lorsqu'en grohl la valeur
du yen mais ce ne sont pas des noms
n'ont pas d'eau pas du tout car quand la
valeur d'une monnaie peut-être
décrédibilisé par les pratiques des
banques centrales à savoir en fait
parler politique monétaire menée par les
banques traditionnellement forcément la
valeur olic qu'est l'or à savoir une
monnaie dans la dans le volume n'évolue
pas en fait en fonction du désir ou du
désir et rata des présidents des banques
centrales forcément ça plutôt tendance à
avoir le vent en poupe et ça c'est
structurel et ça dure ça c'est le
premier point donc le deuxième point
c'était donc dans l'immobilier en
auvergne là où plus personne ne veut
acheter parce que quand personne ne veut
acheter ou en ligne et vous acheter pas
cher et ça c'est le raisonnement un
petit peu de bon père de famille vous à
vocation personnelle c'est ça d'être ma
question les allocations personnel elles
sont dans une maison de famille en seine
et marne que c'est la maison des
grands-parents où j'ai repris donc c'est
rennes a joué contre ma vie et puis le
reste je vais avoir du livret a et du
livret de développement durable de
l'assurance-vie est tous comme ça marque
a pas de crypto monnaie n'y a pas de
hors service de l'assurance vie qui
brésis sur une signature d' et un sessad
roues et ça doit être celle du fou de
fonds en euros assez classique voilà
c'est mon côté très c'est mon côté non
je sais pas si c'est mon père de famille
mais on sait bien que dans l'absolu ça
va pour sa part des éléments savais que
ça laissait renvoie au débat de
l'horizon temporel ça veut dire ça
renvoie à la question de l' horizon
temporel donc y compris à la titre
individuel je pense être je sais pas si
je suis un bon père de famille mais en
tout cas j'essaye donc je suis plutôt
dans une approche prudentielle aussi
parce que je vais devoir faire des
travaux dans ma maison de famille donc
c'est pas mal aussi d'avoir un horizon
temporel pas trop long crypto bonne et
je réponds bah c'est un élément
important pour tout le monde notre point
de vue il est extrêmement clair sur le
sujet ça parte massa porte mal son nom
circule pour que pour être une monnaie
il faudra dossier un pouvoir politique
qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas il n'y a
pas de monnaie qui existent sans le
pouvoir de légiférer voulait décidé en
fête ou d'être adossé avec un pouvoir
politique donc c'est un actif qui peut
monter monter jusqu'au ciel qui peut
descendre mais aussi qui peut descendre
jusqu'à 0 parce qu'en réalité c'est un
actif ça une valeur intrinsèque mais ce
n'est pas une monnaie parce que du jour
au lendemain elle peut être interdite
par le pouvoir politique dans laquelle
en fait nous dans laquelle une zone en
fête aurait décidé en fait qu'elle
n'aurait pas voix au chapitre
le coc vide vous l'avez vu venir vous a
guidé scénario
terme d'épidémie est ce que vous étiez
comme tf1 qui des deux des 2000 ou de
2003 avait déjà commencé à anticiper son
activité professionnelle autour d'une
épidémie est ce que vous aviez ce type
de scénario qui était déjà dans les
dossiers on a fait on est si oui comment
vous avez fait pour la voir dans les
dossiers alors non on n'avait pas de
scénario comme le co vide mais on avait
des scénarios à l'art en termes de plan
de continuité d'activité qui était on
avait des choses sur la question du
risque inondation et autres donc pour
être très vite à autre c'est à dire de
vous décrire des transports va ou
démente transport d'interaction
transport des éléments plus je suis pas
autour de catastrophe naturelle je vais
plutôt le formuler comme ça et puis
c'est vrai qu'on avait eues vous pensez
que faisait le lien avec les transports
ou pour ceux qui sont en ile de france
on a vu des éléments d'interruption les
transports en décembre dernier pour
premiers points 2e point on avait à la
veille du coc vite déjà 45 cents
salariés en télétravail
à la veille de la période de ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'on avait déjà
nous depuis un an et demi à une
diffusion du télétravail on avait déjà
près d'un salarié sur deux qui étaient
en télétravail donc pour eux on a élargi
il ya l amplitude de travail et pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas encore le travail
on essaie on les a équipés fait basculer
en télétravail donc ce qui fait que dans
notre cas on a su garantir la continuité
de notre activité puisque 92 93 % de
deux de nos collaborateurs étaient en
télétravail est ce que les services de
renseignement sont en contact avec vous
pour vous aider dans votre prospective
dans votre capacité à voir une pointe de
diamant pour décrypter des chiffres il à
venir non mais on a on participe à des
travaux avec tracts faim qui ont évoqué
tout à l'heure les problématiques de
cette manière là et donc comme les
autres comme d'autres organismes de
protection sociale on participe à des
travaux de trac fin on participe aussi à
des travaux et le gds haine pour tout ce
qui est continuité d'activité sur ses
juges ce qu'ils aient des et dsn traiter
la chaîne herald la défense nationale
tout ce qui est celle à partir on si
c'est à dire tout ce qui est cyber
attaques et autres parce que ce que vous
évoquez là ils seront qu'on a on a la
qualité d'opérateur de services
essentiels c'est à dire qu'effectivement
on doit garantir le paiement des
retraites y compris dans des conditions
jeu les dires de risque cyber et autres
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on
a des échanges la
c2a temps de l'inde si notre attaque se
trouve qu'on a
comment dirais-je on a notre propre
datacenter en france et vous d'accord
ouais et donc et on a et on est bas que
paie par un grand homme un grand
organisme aussi en france à 500
kilomètres rappelle comment pivot libé m
voilà donc on est un système bmc que la
législation alors
c'est sûr dit des choses qui sont basés
en france d'accord mais mais mais ibm il
traitant de la honte un abat d'ornon et
en euros là d'accord mais ibm est ce que
ibm à des activités en dollars un
message en ce sens je ne sais pas mais
une âme en occident des activités en
dollars est-ce qu'ils doivent collaborer
avec le pouvoir américain ça comment
dirais-je heures ça on renvoie dans un
autre débat après c'est ce que nous
sommes tous espionnés ça renvoie au
débat de 91 pour savoir si par exemple
il ya des échanges de données françaises
par l'intermédiaire d'un non parce que
là nos données nous donner sombre son
datacenter est exploité par l'agirc
arrco pour l'agirc arrco à consommer
temps et en france fed en france il est
surtout c'est nous qui l'avons il est
notre propre premier de propriété de
notre propre exposition donc ce que
j'évoque la cecc uniquement on a un
scénario de backup parce que je suis
posé la question mais vous savez bien
vous avez trouvé des armes à qui nous
avons un backup et pour prendre pour
prendre ce back up on a pris un acteur
qui avaient les reins suffisamment
solides et qui ont peu sa mère de sept
doigts qui était à 500 kilomètres d'une
autre pour éviter des questions du
risque d'inondation et autres la mémé
les données sont vos données qui sont
notre patrimoine immatériel cette
question là les
majors pour nous elle est majeure pour
nous le pentest ça vous fait penser un
coin le pentest vous écrivez peine
comment pénétrer xiam tu estimes sadaoui
on est on est régulièrement testés avec
ont fait nous mêmes nos propres tests
comment vous organisez vos propres tests
ont fait appel justement on fait des
tests anti intrusion fait tester par qui
bat par un certain nombre de sociétés
qui tombe dans ses deux métiers et on a
dit aussi au sgdsn de nous tester vous
en avez trois de société pour ça trois
endroits non pour n'avoir plus que trois
au moins trois nous je vous donnerai pas
les noms
bah non
parce que je peux vous dire attendez ce
sujet de la donne et j'aurais pu dire
quand je vous ai présenté tout à l'heure
comme on gère les données de tout le
monde c'est un sujet qui est majeur pour
nous c'est un sujet majeur c'est un
sujet majeur et irwin et surtout que
c'est pas nos données cd votre cv
viennent dire que les propriétaires de
la donne et c'est la donnée de chacun
d'entre nous et surtout parce qu'au
final quand on part en retraite on va
chercher les données de 45 40 45 ans du
professionnel donc c'est pour ça que
c'est une donnée majeure donc c'est pour
ça qu'on est ycompris sur des systèmes
qu'on a voulu stillman fremm parce que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour quelqu'un qui va l'extérieur c'est
pour ça qu'on a un datacenter qui
l'exploité par nous parce qu'on veut
absolument sécuriser cette donnée là qui
est notre musique là encore c'est un des
éléments la confiance oui c'est un des
éléments de la confiance c'est moi je
moi j'avais posé la question quand on
évoquait tout à l'heure le débat des
idées c'est un jour se poser la question
un gestionnaire d'actifs et vous à
jacquard cause si vous vous nous devez
nous noté et la réponse que m'a fait la
personne m'a dit mais moi vous est
durable parce que vous avez retrouvé mon
job d'été dia qu'il ya 40 ans et sa
poupe pour cette personne là c'est un
caractère s'est incarné le caractère du
rush m'attendais pas à cette réponse en
voilà mais sur ce côté mais finalement
vous avez la résidence et vous avez de
la mémoire et c'est notre capacité comme
on gère un risque l'ont pas finalement y
compris sur certaines personnes je dois
aller jusqu'à un siècle de données entre
la vie professionnelle la retraite la
réversion est ciblé par des puissances
étrangères on a je pourrais vous dire
que une journée donnée on peut avoir
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'
attaque s'asseyant au type qui risque 10
super héros et nos tests nos tests
ancien président à être tout ça je
m'assis et des puissances mais on est
comme d'autres organismes on se fait on
a régulièrement des attaques et des
attaques qui viennent d'un certain de
nombre de pays dans le bon puisque
communiquer quand vous faites poutre et
on communique pas parce qu'on appelle on
a l'occasion c'est pas ne sais pas nous
ne s'est pas reproduite
ces deux crises tout de même la mise à
mort est déjà écrite mais non mais non
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que cet élément il est stratégie pour
nous donc on peut même dire que certains
ont dit mais ce que vous faites pas de
là sur qualité là dessus mais pour nous
c'est majeur c'est majeur donc aucun
système n'est parfait mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'on ait une
vigilance absolue
à dire et à nous tester à retester
outils sait combien je vous donnerai pas
je peux pas vous dire c'est que c'est un
élément majeur pour nous c'était un
élément est majeur pour nous c'est un
élément majeur on consacre chaque année
300 millions d'euros aux dépenses de
systèmes d'information je peux vous dire
que c'est les dépenses sur ces sujets là
sont de plusieurs millions d'euros voilà
pour revenir sur la prospective qu'ovide
je voulais rajouter quelque chose
je sais pas si c'est ce que j'ai répondu
à votre question vous savez le client
est roi donc c'est vous le client les
agences de notation vous en pensez quoi
oh là là on élargit j'abats si vous
voulez je pense que nous quand on est
amené à choisir notre univers
d'investissement
évidemment amené à tenir compte des
notes qui sont qui sont attribuées par
les agences de notation aux supports
d'investissement que nous avons donc en
descendant on descend pas un certain
d'un certain niveau de risque là encore
c'est un élément de la confiance à moi
je ne peux pas aller expliqué je le dis
souvent je peux pas l'expliquer des
ouvriers français
qui ont pour qui la retraite c'est leur
patrimoine que moi avec leurs
cotisations je vais aller faire des
investissements risqués à l'autre bout
du monde avec un prise de risque balance
on assume le fait que le caractère bon
père de famille qu'on ne descend pas en
dessous d'un certain niveau de risque en
termes de support la bêtise vous vous
rappelez 2008 de buch et des huiles ce
monsieur mais on était on avait eu la
chance de se sortir de la grèce un peu a
auparavant voilà sortir de la grèce un
peu un vent
énorme élan mais je le dis avec beaucoup
d'humilité vous savez refaire l'histoire
après c'est toujours facile
mais refaire l'histoire c'est toujours
facile mais nous ne pas via ne pas voir
la tempe est arrivé c'est rigolo alors
donc les agences de notation vous leur
faites confiance j'ai pas dit que je
devrais je dis simplement je réponds à
la question c'est que quand vous menez
gens chez une agence de notation
chinoise a vu le jour moi ce que je ce
que je sais c'est qu'on est plutôt
apprendre les agences de l'onu les
cotations des grandes agences moody's
standard and poor sa fiancée la savoure
continue fitch et choses comme ça et
autres savage et j'ai gagné à questions
pour un champion
mais si on aime lire la notation c'est
un critère relatif fait mieux sur mes
chefs là je vous poserai pas la question
parce que cela poserait plus tôt à vos
prestataires à savoir aux gens à qui
vous faites pas vous donner en fait à
gérer en fait tout mais concrètement au
total vous parlez d'obligations de la
notation est au sujet complexe tout
simplement parce que il ya une borne en
dessous de laquelle par exemple vous
n'êtes pas bon vous êtes dangereux est
une autre une borne au dessus de
laquelle vous êtes bon tri mais au c'ur
a été c'est que la frontière parfois est
fragile et lorsque vous regardez par le
marché obligataire des obligations
marché de la dette en fait dans le monde
et vous regardez en fait les banques les
entreprises à les émettre des
obligations en fait elles émettre de la
dette pour pouvoir se financer car vous
regardez sur l'ensemble de l'univers
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de la dette qui
est émise c'est du triple b c'est-à-dire
le niveau d'eau des aplats de notation
triple à double a et cetera jusqu'à
triple b en dessous duquel vous êtes la
dame à la catégorie spéculative khedri
risqué voire super risques et il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui tout ce qui est
financée et financé quasiment 60% aux
deux tiers sur des obligations
d'entreprises qui sont notées triple b
c'est à dire qu'est ce qui se passe si
un retournement conjoncturel a été le
triple b il fait quoi il descend kéhi
dessin catégorie spéculative c'est pour
ça que les banques centrales sont un
peuple et aiment allier quand vous avez
mis en place des mécanismes de ce type
en réalité vous ne pouvez pas laisser
tomber les marchés parce que si vous
laissez tomber les marchés l'essentiel
dans parce qu'il faut bien faire quelque
chose bien des investissements étant
faits sur des finalement des critères de
risque qui pourraient être remises en
question et bien si jamais la
conjoncture dégradée bien vous pourriez
être en situation il faudrait tout
vendre et tous soldés donc la notion de
notation elle est extrêmement relative
et et c'est pour ça qu'on pourrait
s'interroger sur le fait de deux feux je
pense qu'il faut qu'aujourd'hui les
acteurs construire leur propre grille
d'un dossier de notation c'est compliqué
en fait de faire confiance à des agences
de notation dans le boulot on fait des
noms d'été tout le monde déjà sur des
critères qui sont souvent décrites or
généraliste et qui peuvent être parfois
en fait plutôt des critères d'ordre
réglementaire que véritablement
concourir en fait en photo arrivé en
fait réussir à évaluer concrètement le
risque associé à la signature d'une
entreprise ou d'un état enfin en même
temps là aussi je vous dirais maintenant
se sert plus à rien puisque la banque
centrale finance tout non mais nous si
vous une belle barre j'évalue raison
mais nous on était quand on quand on est
amené à segmenter
dos présente bien et ce moment on a on
évoquait la partie actions obligations
dans chaque classe d'actifs on est amené
à segmenter aussi en fonction du niveau
de risque si oui il n'ya pas de sécurité
absolue c'est ce qu'on est en train de
se dire mais on essaye au maximum
d'avoir une approche où on va pas faire
que du triple b prendre simplement de
cet exemple là on va ça va dépendre
aussi parce qu'on habille support ou
parce que vous évoquiez c'est la
question ou si c'est là c'est
l'arbitrage entre eux rendent moins
liste mais nous on est dans un don quand
on est sur la question de gestion
d'actifs l'arbitrage dans un temps un
triptyque entre la performance le risque
et les coûts de gestion et donc on
essaie de trouver le bon le bonnard le
rond point de rencontre c'est pour ça
qu'on sait morte quand on quand on a
investi en obligations souveraines en
zone euro par rapport à ce que vous
dites de la bce nous sommes que le
risque était assez limité mais le
rendement est assez limité aussi
al'inverse quand on est en action
internationale la performance peut être
plus élevé mais le risque plus élevé on
est après dans les questions de budget
des risques et des donc on est le seul
sujet c'est qu'à la fin on essaie
d'avoir tous les oeufs dans le même
panier si vous me permettez l'expression
pour arriver à se dire effectivement
s'il ya une classe d'actifs qui étaient
amenés à avoir plus de difficultés ou à
plonger il yad'autres les actifs qui
vont moins aller après la vraie question
c'est l'excellente tout à l'heure c est
ce qu on raisonne à 15 jours je voudrais
six mois sur l'a15 en savez quand on
évoquait la question déco vidéo est ce
qu'on sait c'est dans les premières
semaines les marchés financiers ont été
moins liquides ou un profond et puis au
bout d'un mois et demi deux mois ils ont
retrouvé la lisibilité de la profondeur
et du central non mais dominique raspaud
bien sûr mais ce que je veux dire par là
par pour la question quand je prends on
prenait reprenez l'évolution du cac
c'est tout simple il est passé à moins
de 4 milles il est remonté à 4800 je
prendrai donc tout ce que je veux dire
par là c'est là où la question du
caractère et si donc il déterminant
est-ce que je raisonne est-ce que je
suis un investisseur de court terme et
auquel cas je jouais toujours trier mais
je doit empocher une perte ou au
contraire comme c'est notre cas on est
un investissement de moyen terme d sur
un horizon d'investissement du 10 où
quand et comme on est comme on a
segmenté même s'il ya des classes
d'actifs qui peuvent connaître un moment
une forte baisse bah on a un peu de
temps devant nous pour aussi pouvoir
mais ça va pas du tout je vous dis on
est sur du 10 12 ans on est sur du 10 ou
12 ans la mecque en quatre mois il
aurait pas eu la banque centrale en fait
80 mais si j'ai fait un peu taquin comme
du bétail sans eau potable nous serons
tous morts mais non mais la réalité
c'est que théorique
plutôt keynes ou plutôt hayek j'ai
l'impression quand même quand qu en
europe keynes a eu plus d'émules kayek
oui c'est un peu le principe des sectes
je sais pas si c'est la pratique de
sectes ou pomme mais machine question
parce que par rapport à la gestion donc
si je peux me permettre à l'imposer du
président question c'est quelles sont
vos objectifs de performance par rapport
à pascal un vrai sujet majeur pas
peureux l'agirc-arrco mais en général
c'est quoi les objectifs de performance
plein de votre portefeuille financier
j'ai tendance j'aurais du mal à vous
faire un objectif dans l'absolu parce
que ça dépend aussi à l'état des marchés
mais si je vous fais le jeu fait le
retour sur khaled était notre
performance sur les cinq à sept
dernières années alors je vais lycée ou
six parce qu'avec il ya des années 20 -
c'est bon en moyenne on a un
portefeuille avec la segmentation que
j'évoquais 30 70 avec l'univers
d'investissement que j'ai fauté avec
l'horizon d'investissement que
j'évoquais on a été entre 4 et 5% de
rendement annuel donc donc je ne vois là
je ne sais pas si c'est bien ou pas bien
et en tout cas par rapport à la nôtre
horizon d'investissement à ce qu'on
l'accepté en termes de risque pendant le
rendement que nous avons on va le
rendement que nous avons obtenus mais
quand c'est envier aux débats sur la
question des projections quand je
projette le régime on est plus prudent
puisque je fais une hypothèse nous
faisons une hypothèse de rendement de 1%
en réel volontairement donc quand on
fait plus et ben c'est mieux mais mais
en tout cas dans les autres ont donc un
grand votre robinet qui c'est un pur
sang allongé les vaccins objectif c'est
plutôt mon stress test c'est mon c'est
mon scénario de jeu passe si je peux
faire mieux voilà mais c'est dans le jeu
je peux faire mais là où je suis mais en
tout cas nous de scénario il passe avec
encore 1 % 1 % même question d'internet
il ya quelqu'un qui souhaiterait avant
la marque de votre mouvement et cmn qui
les trouve très jolie bague et en plus
elle est française elle sa selle mais ce
n'est pas du tout s'appelle pierre
lannier qui éveille fabriqués en france
et sur un prêt et c'est après tout à
fait raisonnable
voilà pire non par rapport à ça en fait
c'est important lorsque le problème de
l' objectif souvent c'est que vous gérez
en fait un portefeuille avec qui un
portefeuille important pour les français
parce que c'est une partie en fait des
leurres réserves financières pour leur
retraite la question de l'objectif est
toujours crucial cirque eu en fait on
peut pas se fixer un objectif et c'est
souvent ce que nous on observe en fait
chez directeur financier un objectif
dans l'absolu on va prendre 3 4% la
réalité c'est lorsque vous avez une
obligation d'état qui vous rémunère du
zéro continuer à avoir des objectifs
aussi fort vous amène entre guillemets à
faire des choix qui sont des choix trop
agressif par rapport à la promesse que
vous fait la promesse que vous faites
qui sont la promesse aux français que
vous faites d'une certaine manière qui
ont géré les régimes de retraite qui est
tout simplement je vous assurez votre
retraite du mieux mais la première
mission c'est d'abord la préservation de
leur capital et au mieux c'est la
préservation optimale il faut pas que
l'optimal de vienne entre guillemets
l'objectif prioritaire
de la préservation et c'est là où il
faut faire très très attention en
général sur le monde dans le monde
financier parce que se donner des
objectifs qui sont toujours les mêmes
dans le temps par exemple on a fait 4 %
dans le passé donc on se fixe comme
objectif 4% le monde a changé et le fait
est que pour obtenir ces 4% là et bien
vous sortirez entre guillemets du mandat
que vous ont apporté entre guillemets
les les
nouveaux actionnaires à savoir les
concitoyens qui doivent toucher en fait
j'ai été vite et vous avez à son jeu red
j'aurais dû préciser dans ma réponse on
analyse de référence qu'est le msi a eu
qui nous permet de nous comparer mais
qu'on n'a pas un objectif en à
performance absolue mais on est en
relative huit ans quand on se compare on
est en relatif donc ça c'est un élément
c'est vrai que j'évoquais le seul
élément que vous trouvez comme élément
de référence et de 1% en réel dans nos
projections alors l'impact des panamas
peppers et autres évasions fiscales sur
la jirs qui a recours par coup
franchement on va pas investir dans ces
terrains-là va pas investir dans un rôle
assez sais pas ce que vous évoquez
images je sais pas et je saurais pas
vous expliquer d'expliquer à vos
auditeurs que je suis digne de la
confiance si je vais aller facile si on
allait sur les vrais paradis fiscaux au
pardon mais ccc on serait d'une
incohérence absolue surtout c'est
pourquoi 50 absolue parce que on essaye
quand même de privilégier un endroit où
les gens cotisent à l'agirc arrco face à
ces questions de cohérence savez c'était
la question du duo flooring il ya
quelques années politique d'achat
réduction des couches d'époque est un
moment on nous dit vous pouvez réduire
vos coûts si vous délocalisez une partie
de vos centres informatiques en dehors
de la france et de 10 noms on a dit non
parce qu'on n'était pas cohérent et donc
on a réduit nos coûts là mais on n'a pas
été jusqu'à avoir un émissaire droit et
un ami c'est à gauche qui recolle pas et
le sujet des paradis fiscaux c'est le
même sujet estime dans les biotech les
secteurs pharmaceutiques les labours et
sayah il ya une parte pas récemment mais
dans notre comme on est sur du 10 12 ans
il ya une partie de notre activité qui
est investi notamment dans ce secteur là
mais comme moi ils partent les
augmentations qui dit les auvergnats
sont très solides et un exactement mais
c'est pas moi mon auvergne aller en
haute loire
est ce que votre question il faut qu'on
les prenne un peu la folie qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la théorie de
l'effondrement plus tôt
j'avais entendu parler de ça c'est celle
actuelle parce que sur cette question la
théorie de l'effondrement c'est collapse
c'était inouï sur la question
si vous voulez c'est tout le débat de
est ce que c'est la fin du monde demain
ou est-ce que si on se remonte tous les
manches
sauver votre nom le no 2 en or notamment
de la remontée de notre source d'infos
parents le monde le nôtre avec deux
enfants qu'est ce que voit le monde le
monde ou fait 35 ans
jeudi le monde sait qu'on pourrait dire
je pourrais dire l'humanité qu'est ce
qu'on veut les hyènes aux enfants qu'est
ce qu'on vole et gagnent au moins
ça m'arriverait oui bien sûr oui mais je
pense que exactement jeu j'aime bien sa
saison la haute loire j'aime bien le
soi-disant la loire et aux questions
croissance décroissance est-ce que vous
croyez à la décroissance qui est
l'impact d'une décroissance sur un
système financier qui est l'impact d'une
décroissance sur le système des
retraites mais je pense qu'on est là on
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que d'une certaine manière le débat je
sais pas si c'est le débat de la
décroissance c'est comment on arrive à
financer nos goûts nos nos grands
systèmes avec une faible croissance je
pense que c'est ça la question politique
est effectivement c'est une question
pour oddo table sur la croissance
décroissance surtout n'en faisant pas un
débat pour le coup politique ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que souvent les
gens croient qu'en fait on décide de
tout y est quand même des choses qui
sont la conséquence de ce que nous
sommes et je reviens à cette notion
concrètement il faut enfin on peut dire
l'inflation va revenir on va refaire de
la croissance ce qui vous dit ça d'une
certaine manière son déconnectée parce
que demain il va falloir qu'on se fasse
avec des niveaux de croissance qui sont
faibles voire des pays qui seront en
décroissance mais c'est pas quelque
chose en fait qu'on en espère ou qu'on
souhaite c'est globalement en fait un
état de fait qui doit s'imposer à nous
et qui doit nous pousser à gérer
remettre en question nos modèles de
société pour vivre avec est donc le vrai
sujet c'est celui de comment on fait
pour fait pour adapter sans effondrement
sans rupture plus que d'effondrement
comment on fait pour adapter sans
rupture un modèle de société que nous
avons conçu il ya à peu près quatre cinq
six décennies dans la plupart des pays
riches du monde qui reposait sur des
niveaux de croissance qui était très
élevé des populations plus jeunes
comment fait pour l'adapter sans éviter
la rupture serons nous capables de
l'adapter pour répondre aux nouveaux
besoins des populations donc avec moins
de croissance des nouveaux besoins
une proximité renouveler des questions
environnementales qu'il faudrait
intéresser des programmes d'aidé
question d'équité plus que de justice
faisait compliqué de justice et d'équité
a minima fiscale qu'il faudra aussi
adressé comment on fait pour réadapter
finalement toutes les fondations du
modèle qui nous ont fait ya maintenant
quarante ou cinquante ans sans aller
jusqu'à la rupture et là la question
fondamentale c'est celle de comment on
orchestre ce changement sauf que pour
lorsque on change il y aura toujours des
gagnants mais la réalité c'est lorsqu'on
aura renouvelé ce modèle il est probable
que les gagnants de demain ne soit pas
les gagnants d'aujourd'hui et les
difficultés qu'on a souvent à adapte un
modèle c'est tout simplement qu'ils
aient un effet de résistance des acteurs
en place donc à ce changement là parce
que globalement dans les nouvelles
regrette le de jeu qu'il faudra édicter
ils ne sont pas sûrs de préserver leur
position dominante donc le vrai sujet il
est là c'est un gros c'est pas
effondrement ou pas c est ce qu'on sera
capable d'éviter la rupture pour adapter
nos modèles à quel que soit ce qui
s'impose à nous à savoir des niveaux de
croissance du chanteur gay men comme
tout fait mais j'attends que tous d'être
chez nous tous les cantons prend notre
histoire vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
il ya 50 ans need to fail c'est la
version c'est trop gros pour s'effondrer
ça c'est sympa ça veut dire quand même
que le préjugé sur l'agirc-arrco ils
parlent pas un mot en anglais il a rien
compris la finance durable ça
c'est pas
vrai et 2 on adore votre accent dehors
de ces mots des mots guédé auvergne
alger j'ai vraiment perçu images
arrivent de la haute loire c'est ça je
dois dire je plaisante non alors non le
propos pour ma part parce que c'est ce
qu'on disait instance et c'est de se
dire dans nos débats si la transition
est un sujet en soi on sous-estimé
l'importance de la transition contre
parle d'un mode et nalout du sujet on
pense que on raisonne dans l'absolu on
raisonne pas en relatif premier point le
deuxième élément moi je pense que la
question moi que nous pose règle et
avancent et qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
épater et donc je pense que la question
majeure sur les débats comme ça sur le
caractère durable c'est que faisons-nous
chacun d'entre nous dans notre champ de
responsabilités pour faire évoluer ce
sujet mais y compris dans nos
comportements individuels y compris dans
nos eaux dans nos habitudes et smash que
ça ça renvoie aussi à notre
responsabilité mais est-ce que vous dont
vous aimeriez vous avez prévu un
référendum à riom où vous rentrez en
défaut de paiement
vous voulez on n'est pas rentré dans
cela parce qu'on a on a tout fait pour
justement avoir dessiné pour ne jamais
arriver au défoulement quand je suis à 6
mois de réserve c'est pour pas arriver
justement c'est en défaut de paiement
sinon j'aurais pas une règle d'or à six
mois et réserve ses élans il ya un
moment donné où
il faut nous aider vous êtes obligés
d'en fait d'aller voir l'étape semaine
d'après les médias il n'ya pas mais
évidence il ya un système qui imagine un
réveil que une faillite en fait de
l'agirc arrco s'est en fait juste
impossible donc la question de fond
c'est qu'on entre guillemets on
collectivise les pertes puisque en gros
ils voudraient qu'on sans délai la colle
aux collectivités s'endettent pour faire
face à la situation
mais il est évident que si jamais il ya
un problème de cette nature là et que ça
doit toucher beaucoup de monde ça sera
pas loin d'être les premiers à être
sauvé mais parce que collectivement
parlant on ne peut absolument pas et
donc à la question too big to fail
évidemment encore plus peut-être pas
plus mais en tout cas autant que les
banques en fait il qu est ce donc ça va
ils ne peuvent pas entrer ni sortir si
le 6 2 6 2 et gds elle nous a qualifiés
de d'opérateurs services essentiels
s'était pas sur l'argument financier
c'est ce que vous dites sur vous ne
pouvez pas interrompre aux opérations de
paiement
nommé avec l'argument leurs arguments
c'était l'exemple de la nouvelle orléans
un entretien si vous en été on perd nos
têtes
non c'était cet été l'argument de se
dire vous rappelez nouvelle-orléans
interruption l'activité économique et
les états américains pour relancer
l'activité économique qu'ils ont choisi
ces données des dollars mais c'était
cette idée de relancer et donc l'analyse
et laon dans les débats d'autres pays
des risques c'est de se dire on sait que
la vie économique la continuité de la
vie est quand même dit qu'ils étaient un
sujet majeur et donc et donc c'est pour
ça que le risque il ya un sujet qu'on
évoquait direct qui sous jacent mais
aussi les contournent évoqué la question
du cyber risque si on se faisait à qui
demain on aura les problématiques mais
comme nous comme les banques comme
n'importe quel organe c'est raté oui ça
c'est la version pour montrer qu'on
savait traduire aussi donc voilà mais
donc voilà donc pour moi cette question
elle est comment dirais-je fusion il ya
la question de l'état prêteur en dernier
ressort mais quand on évoquait la
question des banques la collection des
grandes compagnies c'était un peu le
même sujet c'est dans d'autres pays que
dans quelle mesure les tailles et le
prêteur en dernier ressort c'est ça la
question nous simplement on fait tout
pour arriver sur nos propres réserves
sur nos propres moyens sur ces atouts la
question des règles d'or pouvoir faire
face à ses élèves c'est effectivement le
monde s'effondre demain c'est pour ça
que l'état vous a fait passer un petit
message pour pas vous donner de sousse
énorme blague c'est un sujet de
trésorerie là honnêtement c'était pas
s'était insurgé purement conjoncturelle
n'était pas un sujet de principe si je
vais tout est toujours conjoncture pas
du tout non mais ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que la preuve c'est que l'état
nous a repris notre attaché il ya dix
jours en serbie autour d'une table voilà
donc pour vous dire que le sujet n'est
pas un sujet définitif parce qu'on
revient au fait que les marchés de
trésorerie à court terme retrouvait la
profondeur et la liquidité
autre question et propos je reprends ma
ligne question conséquence européenne de
la décision de la cour constitutionnelle
allemande de 15 trop vis-à-vis du
quantitative easing infinie de la bce
sait c'est pas nouveau si je peux me
permettre cette décision de la cour
européenne est là il y avait déjà eu des
précédents et c'est tout la stagflation
ça veut dire quoi
en fait la bce a dit clairement je m'en
fous puisque très clairement donc alors
ça ça pose un problème politique de
positionnement de qui fait quoi qui a le
droit de faire quoi et simplement ça
sera un sujet de la décennie à savoir
politiquement est-ce qu'il est
acceptable qu'une banque centrale puisse
outrepasser le droit constitutionnel en
fait d'un état le cder c'est un vrai
sujet est majeur un sujet politique mais
on aura probablement on n'arrive pas du
tout à la fin de notre interview
une dernière petite question concernant
la stagflation pacification l'activité
cas-là économiques inflation ses
programmes de seconde de brown économie
au monde si mes souvenirs sont bons
c'est bien mais vous savez on est très
pédagogique
d'accès de les intéresser il va
s'intéresser au sujet des reprises
accorde donc un petit mot un petit mot
sur l'infernal ce tome d'une agression
c'est pas possible simplement pas c'est
bien la voir ce que ça veut dire mais la
question c'est est ce qu'on peut avoir
et de l'inflation la réponse est non
l'inflation juste c'est pas une formule
mathématique c'est tout simplement ce
n'est que la conséquence de
l'augmentation de la demande par rapport
en fait une capacité à les servir c'est
le temps nécessaire pour que le type d
exécution et souvenirs sont bons quand
c'est ce que notre pays a connus à la
fin des essais au 10 ou 12 et 86 des
bureaux de spéculation quand même de
l'inflation qui était avec eux ou second
choc pétrolier alors faisons pas de la
durée l'inflation liée au second choc
pétrolier et il a fait une stagnation
d'activité comme
à oui d'accord mais je pensais que
c'était la question un petit bout d'un
petit mot sur l'affairé alsthom heures
laquelle je me connais plusieurs dans
lequel quelques affaires je ne sais pas
moi j'ai jamais entendu parler games une
affaire alstom et à la fin des années 90
et aux autres mais pour ça que je ne
sais pas c'est quoi tout récemment c'est
quoi c'était là il est question de
rachat d'alstom par general electric
c'est bien à la cbc pour savoir si je
suis la presse économique qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais qu'est-ce que gérant
français c'est pas le sujet de comment
dirais-je c'était tout le débat d'après
ce que alstom de mémoire d'esclave et la
masse critique ou pas la masse critique
royal doit la souveraineté après ça
envoie vous savez alors je reviens je
refais mon publi reportage quand je
discute avec l'autorité des marchés
financiers elle me dit la mef exactement
elle me dit on a besoin najac un coût
pour la profondeur et la liquidité la
place financière de paris pourquoi
normes pourquoi dis ça c'est 30 70 quand
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la plupart des
investisseurs institutionnels ou une par
action plus faible parce que notamment
quand vous êtes assurément si vous êtes
ne vous êtes soumis un soldat deux
premiers points deuxième élément vous
avez un horizon d'investissement qui est
plutôt une quête huit ans que du 12 ans
donc tout ça pour dire que je pense que
par rapport à votre question nous c'est
pour ça que notre nom n'a jamais autant
d'actions halak certains pourraient dire
les actions c'est plus variable mais
c'est aussi pour jouer ce rôle j'irai
d'investisseurs de moyen terme sur la
place financière de paris c'est quoi le
bonheur pour le départ en retraite c'est
le bonheur c'est celui que vous aurez
choisi
on arrive à la fin il faut trois
bouquins conseiller trois bouquins notre
communauté et laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
on va laisser le mot de la fin à pierre
françois xavier alors trois mois moi je
vais peut-être je vais les prendre dans
des ordres différents
un bouquin qui est une
on est sur une année de gaulle l'année
sur une année de gaulle le bouquin qui
pour moi est le plus complet il est dur
c'est le livre de jean lacouture est en
trois tomes qui date des années 80 si
vous je pense que c'est la somme la plus
complète sur le général de gaulle donc
si vous avez envie de ça prend un peu de
temps mais mes acda sommes là c'est la
somme la plus complète le deuxième livre
que je recommanderais c'est le livre
stefan zweig le monde d'hier qui trahi
qui travaillent qui décrit très bien
l'europe centrale à la fin des à la fin
du 19e et où le début du xxème c'est le
dernier c'est quasiment le dernier livre
de stéphane vagues avant qui ne
l'inquiète se suicider ont traduit bien
le basculement d'un monde le basculement
d'un monde et puis pour être dans un 3e
troisième registre lettres à un jeune
poète de rilke un
conseil pour les jeunes générations un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
c'est soyez acteur de votre vie fait des
choix éclairés et et surtout soyez pas
dans les idées reçues
alors les bouquins c'est compliqué il y
en a certains effectivement que je
souscrire est le premier le plus
lointain ça c'est mon côté je suis un
amoureux absolue de stendhal qui pour
moi en fait et est l'auteur français
kiki quelle que soit l'histoire qu'ils
racontent les raconte tellement bien
qu'il faut les lire ces bouquins donc la
littérature ce type alors j'irai
jusqu'au chronique italienne pour
revenir à quel point j'adore le
chroniqueur italienne s'est simplement
il avait récupéré les les minutes en
fait des procès du 16e siècle il les a
réécrit et le fait qu'il l'ait écrit en
fait les magnifie donc voilà c'est mon
côté un peu un peu
passéiste mais stendhal et les
chroniques italiennes très bon le
deuxième qui nous rapproche plus parce
que ça a été un élément quand même
marque en fait de ma construction
intellectuelle c'est le cygne noir de
taleb qui donc
expliquer comment ben si nassim taleb
examinant exactement et qui bat exprimé
théorise un petit peu la notion en fait
d'événements imprévus parce que mon
métier c'est faire de la prospective et
une chose est sûre c'est que il faut
lutter contre cette tendance à projeter
l'avenir comme la continuité de ce qui
s'est passé l'histoire nous montre que
ce n'est jamais comme ça que ça se
produit donc il même si c'est un
événement gérer impossible à imaginer il
faut l'imaginer donc je pensais vraiment
un bouquin à lire le troisième il est
beaucoup plus récent c'est mon épouse
qui me l'a offert s'appelle les ronces
ça c'est mon côté un peu plus rurales je
n'avais plus l'auteur s'est désolé c'est
une femme mais qui raconte en fait
l'histoire du foot voilà exactement
probablement et l'histoire en fait d'une
d'une jeune femme qui se fait qui vit
dans une ferme c'est une de la modernité
et qui est se fait rouler en fait part
par un homme qu'elle aime et et qui
vient cette balle à séduire pour acheter
ces terres est monté un immeuble à la
place et donc c'est une histoire à un
peu intéressante mais qui parle beaucoup
on fait d'un autre époque a conçu pour
le jeu de génération
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire si ce
n'est en fait de rester libre et
autonome
ayez confiance en vous et surtout bâti
ces
bâtisses et pas des grandes choses en
fait bâtisse est en fait les choses les
unes après les autres il n'y a pas de
grandes victoires il ya qu une
succession de petites victoires moi j'ai
suivi en fait j'ai fait le choix de
l'entrepreneuriat à savoir de prendre sa
machette et tracer son propre chemin il
ya très longtemps maintenant je les fais
de multiples reprises c'est un chemin
qui peut être couronnée de succès ou à
la faut pas avoir peur donc pour autant
jean reviendrait à la notion de
confiance faut pas avoir peur faut bâtir
faut avancer mais faut être lucide il
faut pas voir le monde tel qu'on
aimerait qu'il soit mais il faut voir le
monde tel qu'il est et si on s'est posé
ce bon diagnostic là je suis confiant
car chaque jour qui passe quand je suis
dans mes territoire quel que soit le
niveau de diplôme les gens sont
intelligents les gens sont ingénieux
peut-être pas ingénieur mais ingénieux
ils ont cette capacité en fait à s'ils
sont lucides s'il ne croit pas toujours
en fait un monde espérait au rêver il
sans capacité en fait de construire leur
avenir je suis très optimiste messieurs
merci
merci à vous
[Musique]